mes chers collègues je vous propose de
débuter notre audition d'autres
collègues vont certainement nous nous
rejoindre il m plus de temps que
certains à monter les escaliers depuis
l'hémicycle jusque à nous rejoindre ici
dans cette salle de la commission des
affaires économiques madame la ministre
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir dans cette enceinte de
pouvoir vous auditionner dans le cadre
de les crédits sur la mission énergie de
la mission écologie et plus largement
sur l'actualité très dense du secteur de
l'énergie avant de vous donner la parole
pour que vous puissiez nous présenter
votre budget je souhaiterais justement
vous poser quelques questions sur cette
actualité le 25 septembre dernier le
président de la République a annoncé
l'aboutissement de chantier législatif
majeur avec le dépôt d'ici la fin de
l'année d'un projet de loi révisant
notre programmation et notre régulation
énergétique et un autre projet de loi
fusionnant l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire l'ASN avec l'Institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
l'IRSN pouvez-nous nous préciser les
calendriers et les contenus envisagés
dans ces deux textes madame la ministre
je veux le dire solennellement ici notre
commission et je n'en doute pas le Sénat
dans son ensemble sera ser très
attentive au respect des droits du
Parlement dans le cadre de l'examen de
ces deux textes je rappelle que c'est
notre commission qui a fixé le principe
d'une loi quinquénale sur l'énergie lors
du vote de la loi climat énergie de
2019 ce faisant nous avons souhaité dans
un secteur aussi stratégique que celui
de l'énergie consacré la presséance du
Parlement sur le gouvernement de la
politique sur la technique car ces choix
auront des conséquences majeures sur le
quotidien de nos concitoyens nous
n'accepterons donc pas un énième report
d'examen car cette loi je le rappelle
aurait dû légalement être adopté avant
le 1er juillet
2023 nous veillerons aussi à ce que le
contenu de cette loi couvre bien
l'ensemble des enjeux du mix énergétique
à la rénovation énergétique ce contenu
doit courir jusqu'en
2033 s'agissant de l'énergie et jusqu'en
2038 concernant le carbone pour ce qui
est de la fusion de l'ASN et de l'IRSN
c'est aussi notre commission qui a
expurgé la loi nouveau nucléaire de juin
2023 de toute référence à cette fusion
pour pour lui préférer une saisine de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
lopex en rejetant les amendements
présentés à la hâte par le gouvernement
après le vote massif du Sénat sur ce
texte nous nous sommes opposés à une
réforme mal anticipée et mal évaluée en
saisissant l'OPEX nous avons remis les
parlementaires au cœur des enjeux nous n
souhaitons donc des conditions d'examen
qui permettent au Parlement de prendre
le temps d'examiner de façon
approfondies les tenants et les
aboutissants de ce texte nous veillerons
évidemment à ce que le contenu de cette
loi n'induise pas de déstabilisation de
la sûreté de la radioprotection ou de la
recherche nucléaire vous le savez comme
nous pour réussir la relance du
nucléaire pour réussir pardon la relance
du nucléaire doit être assortie d'un
haut niveau de contrôle de et de
transparence gage de la confiance du
public c'est donc un examen
parlementaire approfondi et exigeant que
notre commission réservera comme à son
habitude à ces textes un travail que
nous voulons être un travail de fond un
travail rationnel et un travail
collégial parmi les sujets pendants je
forme le vœu que c débloque deux sujets
de financement sur lesquels je
souhaiterais vous interroger dans le
domaine du nucléaire les dépenses
s'élève pour le groupe EDF à 50
milliards d'euros pour la construction
de six nouveaux PR2 et à 65 milliards
d'euros pour la prolongation des
réacteurs existants dans le cadre du
grand carénage or aucun modèle de
financement n'a été trouvé à ce jour
aussi madame la ministre nous voudrions
savoir concrètement comment va être
financé votre relance du nucléaire la
réforme de l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire l'arenne est
encore attendue un accord a été annoncé
hier avec un prix autour de 70 € par MWh
en quoi consiste-t-il précisément quel
est son impact sur les recettes du
groupe EDF et les prix des consommateurs
par ailleurs les contrats pour
différence autorisés pour l'énergie
nucléaire par la réforme du marché
européen de l'électricité ne sont non
plus opé ne sont pas non plus
opérationnels monsieur lucrémont le PDG
de DF que nous avons auditionné la
semaine dernière a rappelé devant cette
commission la nécessité d'un soutien
public quel qu'il soit pour réussir la
relance du nucléaire comment l'État
va-t-il aider EDF à financer ses plus de
100 milliards d'investissements je
rappelle que le montant alloué au
nucléaire par le plan par le plan France
2030 ne dépasse pas 1 milliard d'euros
comment dès lors développer les PR 2 et
SMR annoncé à l'chelan européen les
modèles de financement passent par des
fonds propres par des garanties
d'emprunt par des prix régulés ou par
des participations de consommateurs
intensifs quel est le schéma retenu pour
la France en sachant que la Cour des
comptes a clairement indiqué que le
groupe EDF ne pouvait financer seul
cette relance enfin dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables les dépenses
atteignent selon le groupe EDF 5
milliards d'euros par an s'agissant des
investissements dans la transition
énergétique pour
l'hydroélectricité Monsieur Raymond nous
a précisé qu'il étudiait un passage du
régime des concessions vers celui des
autorisations c'est une annonce
importante dans la mesure où un
contentieux européen Auer les
perspectives de développement de la
filière et ce depuis bientôt 20 ans
quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénients de cette solution le
gouvernement est-il sur la même longueur
d'onde que le groupe EDF en la matière
voilà madame la ministre ces premières
questions auxquelles je souhaiterit que
vous puissiez répondre mais bien sûr
aussi nous présenter votre budget dans
le cadre du PLF 2024 et ensuite nos
rapporteurs qui sont intervenus soit sur
avis sur les crédits énergies de la
mission écologique et je pense bien sûr
à Daniel grmiller mais un certain nombre
de nos collègues qui ont conduit des
travaux soit sur les propositions de loi
soit sur des missions d'information
compléterons mes questions et ensuite
nous ouvrirons plus largement le débat
auprès l'ensemble auprès de l'ensemble
de nos collègues madame la ministre je
vous laisse bien volontiers la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vous propose de commencer
par le budget et de répondre ensuite
aussi rapidement que possible à vos
questions qui sont importantes et
nombreus je me permettrai d'abord un mot
madame la Présidente pour saluer
votre élection à à à ce poste j'en suis
certaine j'aurai le même plaisir de
travailler d'échanger que celui que j'ai
eu avec Madame la vice-présidente Sophie
prima que je salue également je suis
donc très heureuse de cette première
audition sur votre présidence consacrée
au budget 2022 du ministère de la
transition énergétique mais qui
manifestement va s'ouvrir 2024 pardon
vous avez raison mais qui va
manifestement s'ouvrir à bien d'autres
sujets ce budget porte un effort inédit
de l'État pour mettre en œuvre la
planification écologique et énergétique
sur les 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dédiés à la
planification 7 milliards seront portés
par les ministères de la transition
écologique et de la transition
énergétique avec un total de 62
milliards d'euros les budgets des deux
ministères sont en hausse de 15 %. ces
moyens financiers s'accompagnent d'un
renforcement conséquent de nos moyens
humains avec la création nette de 760
emplois dans l'administration centrale
comme déconcentrés là encore c'est une
hausse des emplois inédites pour la
haute fonctionnaire que je suis qui a
débuté en 2000 dans l'administration des
finances je crois que c'est du jamais vu
ces moyens sont au service d'une
ambition celle de l'accompagnement des
Français dans la transition écologique
et énergétique celle visant à leur
permettre de mieux se déplacer et mieux
se loger celle visant enfin à permettre
à notre pays de produire plus d'énergie
décarbonée ce budget c'est d'abord celui
de la décarbonation du quotidien des
Français car pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone nous devons nous en
tenir à un principe intangible la
transition écologique et énergétique ne
doit pas aggraver les inégalités
sociales c'est une question
d'acceptabilité je suis convaincu que la
transition synonyme de grande
transformation de nos modes de vie est
une question éminemment sociale et
sous-estimer cette dimension c'est
mettre en risque notre république dont
l'équilibre repose sur une forte
exigence culturellement de justice
sociale au fond la transition écologique
et énerg éthique et plus un sujet de
progrès social que de progrès technique
et quand qu'on accompagne les français
pour qu'ils puissent mieux se déplacer
mieux se loger on marque des points dans
la bataille du pouvoir d'achat et des
factures avec des véhicules qui
consomment moins et des logements moins
énergivores on gagne également des
points dans le combat pour
l'amélioration de la qualité de vie en
réduisant la pollution de l'air les
maladies respiratoires et en permettant
à des millions de Français d'habiter
dans des logements dignes en sortant des
passoirs thermiques et je sais que vous
êtes une spécialiste de ces questions
madame la présidente et dans le même
temps on marque évidemment des points
dans le combat climatique en réduisant
considérablement les principaux postes
émetteurs de gaz et effet de serre que
sont les véhicules des particuliers et
les bâtiments résidentiels le
gouvernement a ainsi fait le choix de
porter à 1,5 milliard d'euros les aide
au verdissement des véhicules soit 200
millions d'euros de plus qu'en 2023
c'est une hausse de 15
%. ça se décline autour de trois axes
nous devons d'abord rendre plus
accessibles les véhicules électriques
aux plus modestes et aux classes
moyennes qui vivent en particulier en
ruralité et en périphérie nous
renforçons ainsi les aides au véhicules
électriques pour ceci mon objectif est
de réduire l'écart entre le prix d'un
véhicule thermique et d'un véhicule
électrique et de le mettre à la portée
des bourses des classes modestes et
moyennes et vous savez qu'un certain
nombre de modèles arrivent sur le marché
à partir de l'année prochaine des
petites voitures électriques qui seront
produites aux alentours de 20 à 25000 €
et là on commence avec les aides à
pouvoir avoir des véhicules qui sont
très proches du coût des véhicules
thermiques sachant qu'un véhicule
thermique coûte 1200 € environ de plus
en carburant chaque année si on prend
une moyenne de déplacement de 12000
km nous mettons euh en place également
la promesse du président de la
République le leasing social à 100 €
destiné au 50 % de nos citoyens de nos
concitoyens les plus modestes les
premiers véhicules éligibles seront
annoncés en décembre nous mettons enfin
en place un score environnemental sur
les véhicules électriques pour ne
financer que ceux qui ont la meilleure
empreinte environnementale il y a
derrière cela la volonté de reconnaître
ou de remettre un élément de concurrence
loyale entre des véhicules électriques
qui sont produits à l'autre bout du
monde avec un bilan carbone en analyse
de cycle de vie beaucoup plus élevé que
des véhicules électriques qui sont
produits en France et en Europe avec une
vraie attention à la manière de produire
au bilan carbone et du coup et bien
l'idée c'est de rééquilibrer cela en ne
donnant de bonus écologiqu qu'aux
véhicules qui ont le meilleur score
environnement
le décret a été publié la liste des
véhicules qui satisferont cette clause
sera connue en fin d'année après
instruction individuelle des dossier
cette enveloppe permettra aussi un
renforcement du soutien de l'État
l'électrification des poids lourds le
texte du projet loi de finance 2024
porte également des mesures de
renforcement des malus sur le CO2 ainsi
que le poids des véhicules pour inciter
à l'achat de véhicules électriques et
plus légers nous poursuivons enfin nos
efforts de déploiement des
infrastructures de recharge avec le
soutien à l'installation pour atteindre
400000 points de recharge publi d'ici
2030 comme s était engagé le président
de la République l'enveloppe sera
précisée dans quelques semaines mais je
peux d'ors et déjà vous confirmer que
les aides certificat d'économie
d'énergie à l'installation des bandes de
recharge au sein des copropriétés des
entrepris ou en voirie publi seront
abondés de 200 millions d'euros pour la
période 24 et 25 des carboner le
quotidien des Français c'est aussi les
aider à mieux se loger à ce titre je
tiens à saluer le travail du Sénat sur
la question de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments votre rapport comporte de
nombreuses propositions qui sont
partagées par le gouvernement et dont
certaines sont d'ors et déjà suivies d'
fait dans ce projet de loi de finance
d'abord sur les moyens budgétaires
consacrés nous mobilisons des moyens
historiques 5 milliards d'euros alloués
au financement des aides à la rénovation
énergétique des logements cela
représente 1,6 milliards d'euros de plus
qu'en 2024 grâce à 2023 grâce à ces
financements moyens de l'ANA connaîtront
une hausse sans précédent pour financer
les aides ma primime Renov ce budget
renforcé permettra d'accélérer
l'installation d'équipement décarbonés
de chauffage et d'augmenter le soutien
aux rénovations d'ampleur en particulier
les passoirs thermiques qui sont un
enjeu de pouvoir d'achat majeur je
rappelle que une passoire thermique
classé g c'est important d'avoir le
chiffre en tête ça coûte trois fois plus
cher en facture trois fois pas 10 % de
plus trois fois en facture qu' un
logement lambda type bon classement d ou
mauvais classement C
euh afin de lutter contre les bouilloirs
thermiques nous allons aussi financer
les aides au confort d'été c'est-à-dire
certains gestes comme la ventilation les
protections solaires par exemple et des
solutions de de climatisation mais
spécifique enfin avec un au niveau
environnemental ce budget en hausse doit
s'accompagner d'une pleine mobilisation
de nos partenaires je pense à la filière
comme vous le soulignnez dans votre
rapport qui doit se structurer
rapidement pour faire des rénovations
performante je pense aussi au
cofinanceurs et acteurs de terrain pour
étaufer les guichets France renve et
accroître le nombre d'accompagnateurs
Renov vous savez qu'on a des ambitions
fortes en la matière vous me permettrez
de m'arrêter un instant sur le sujet du
financement du service public
d'accompagnement des Français dans la
rénovation énergétique c'est un service
public cofinancé entre l'État les
collectivités territoriales ce
cofinancement est la preuve que l'État
dans toutes ses composantes se range
derrière une même ambition celle de
l'amélioration de l'habitat des Français
de la lutte contre contre le dérèglement
climatique dès lors je me permets de de
signaler que le retrait unilatéral d'un
cofinanceur met en péril tout l'édifice
et je ne peux en ce sens que regretter
la décision du président de la Région
Auvergne ronalpe d'arrêter ce ce
financement sur sa région j'appelle de
nouveau le président à revenir sur cette
décision qui va rebour de l'ambition
qu'il nous revient collectivement
d'honorer et met en risque 300
professionnels sur le terrain dont le
travail est d'accompagner
quotidiennement les Français dans leur
projets de rénovation thermique
pour revenir sur les partenaires à
mobiliser je pense également aux banques
qui sont chargé de la distribuer les C
prêt à taux zéro dans le budget 2024 le
gouvernement réaffirme et amplifie ce
dispositif de l'cooptz il sera prorogé
jusqu'en 2027 pour donner la visibilité
nous relevons le plafond de travaux
finançable à hauteur de 50000 € pour les
rénovations multigestes là encore en
reprenant une partie de la proposition
qui figurait dans votre rapport en outre
l'adoption en première lecture des
amendements du député et David Amiel
permettront français de bénéficier du
préavance rénovation à taux zéro comme
vous le proposiez aussi dans votre
rapport et fait important ce prêt avance
rénovation sera ouvert sans condition de
ressources maintenant c'est au banquees
de jouer le jeu auprès de nos
concitoyens pour faciliter l'instruction
de l'octroit de ces prê bonifiés ce
loger c'est enfin pouvoir payer ses
factures d'énergie dans un contexte de
crise je le rappelle nous avons agi vite
et massivement avec des boucliers
tarifaires il s'agit aujourd'hui d'en
sortir progressivement à la faveur du
retour des prix de gros sur les marchés
du gaz et l'électricité à des niveaux
plus habituel tout en soutenant ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin au travers du
chèque énergie le bouclier sur
l'électricité continuera de de
s'appliquer pour les particuliers en
habitat privé ou collectif tout comme
l'amortisseur électricité à destination
des PME collectivité locale et
association audelà de cette cruciale
décarbonation du quotidien le budget est
également celui qui poursuit nos efforts
pour bâtir notre souverereaineté
énergétique grâce à la production
d'énergie décarbonée dans la droite
ligne des deux lois sur l'accélération
des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire que j'ai fait adopter cette
année 1,4 milliards d'euros mobilisés
pour financer le soutien à la
technologie nucléaire on va revenir sur
les eutes financement les subventions
àoué au CEA atteindront 1,2 milliard
d'euros en 2023 intégrant un
renforcement de 200 millions d'euros de
la subvention àoué pour concrètement
faire avancer les projets de SMR et
financer le renforcement des effectifs
du CEA hauteur de6 ETP en parallèle le
soutien du gouvernement aux énergies
renouvelables se poursuivra tout d'abord
un nouveau mécanisme de soutien la
production d'hydrogène décarboné donc
décarboné c'est à la fois sur base
renouvelable et nucléaire qui verra le
jour l'année prochaine par ailleurs les
montants versés au titre de soutien à
l'injection au biogaz et au projets de
transition énergétique dans les zones
non interconnectées augmenteront
également par rapport à 2023 au total
l'état financera 4 milliards d'euros au
titre des charges de service publics de
l'énergie dans le même temps les projets
éoliens continueront d'être bénéfiques
pour le budget de l'État puisqu'ils sont
aujourd'hui plus compétitifs que la
moyenne euh du du prix l'électricité et
donc nous anticipons pour cette année
des reversements pour l'année 2024 des
reversements au budget de l'État ce qui
est une bonne nouvelle parce que ça
montre que le système euh de financement
des ENR joue dans les deux sens et
permet là aussi de stabiliser les prix
de l'électricité euh et de faire un
retour à l'état et que c'estes énergies
sont compétitives en outre le budget
consacré aux études sur l'implantation
de parc éolien augmentera de 55 millions
d'euros pour atteindre 123 millions
d'euros c'est une augmentation de 80 %
mais à l'ône de l'ambition que nous
portons sur l'éolien marin enfin le fond
chaleur qui est très apprécié des
collectivités locales mais également des
industrielles sera augmenté à un niveau
inédit pour atteindre 820 millions
d'euros en 2024 je me permets de
souligner que depuis 2017 nous avons
quadruplé le fond chaleur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous l'aurez
compris ce budget est le pendant
financier du plan de bataille de
planification écologique et énergétique
que je porte il représent un effort
massif pour accompagner les Françaises
et les Français dans la décarbonation de
leur quotidien nous devons poursuivre la
mobilisation collective de tous les
acteurs et donc euh je vais passer à à à
vos questions qui vont éclairer la façon
dont nous pouvons euh également porter
cette ambition juste pour rappeler les
fond notre politique de transition
énergétique vous avez deux piliers la
baisse de la consommation d'énergie
l'augmentation de la production
d'énergie de carboné sur notre
territoire la baisse de la consommation
d'énergie c'est le changement des
habitudes des usages ça s'appelle la
sobriété énergétique sufficiency en
anglais c'est peut-être plus joli parce
que ça fait une relation au juste emploi
des
ressources et ça on a réussi à baisser
je le redis de 12 % notre consommation
de gaz et d'électricité sur les 12
derniers mois c'est énorme et pourtant
on peut aller plus loin et je me
permettrai de remarquer qu'il fait
probablement pas 19°gr dans cette pièce
vous AZ tous très chaud comme moi
euh la deuxème le deuxème levier c'est
l'efficacité énergétique c'est mettre à
profit des technologies et des
investissements pour réduire à usage
égal notre consommation d'énergie c'est
la rénovation thermique c'est les leds
c'est les processus industriels revu
pour revoir notre consommation d'énergie
la prochaine fois je vi avec mon
thermomètre
euh sur la partie euh production ce sont
donc les énergies renouvelables et les
énergies nucléaires et sur ces sujetsl
en 2023 nous sommes dans une situation
où nous n prenons quasiment aucun risque
à pousser les curseurs au maximum parce
que la marche à franchir d'ici 2030 2035
et 2050 lorsqu'on fait tourner les
modélisations et vous savez qu'on a la
chance avec RTE notamment sur la partie
électricité d' avoir une vision très
fine et très approfondie de notre modèle
énergétique et on le complète avec tout
un travail qui a été porté aussi sur sur
la biomasse dans le cadre de la de la
planification écologique nous voyons que
la marche à franchir est très élevée
donc pousser au maximum les curseurs
c'est au fond nous donner toutes les
chances de réussir d'ici 2030- 2035
après certainement les curseurs
s'ajusteront aussi en fonction de notre
rythme de déploiement réel et en
fonction des nouvelles technologies qui
manqu pas d'arriver sur le marché
puisque nous allons investir fortement
aussi dans ces nouvelles technologies et
ne serons et nous ne serons pas les
seuls au au niveau planétaire ce qui
m'amène à la question des projets de
loi vous le savez nous avons travaillé à
une stratégie française énergie climat
depuis maintenant 1 an avec une phase de
concertation du public qui a duré entre
le mois d'octobre et le mois de
février je vous avais d'ailleurs invité
membrre de la commission des affaires
économiques et du développement durable
à la restitution des travaux du Forum
des jeunesses que nous avions organisé
nous avons ensuite lancé des groupes de
travail auquel certains ici ont
participé sur notre planification
énergétique et qui a qui ont fait des
donc SEP groupes de
travail parlementaires élus locaux
entreprises association de consommateurs
association environnemental experts
organisation syndicales qui ont rendu le
contenu de de leur proposition en
septembre le président de la République
a repris une large part de ses
propositions dans sa planification
écologique qui a été présentée à la fin
du mois de septembre et je finalise ce
document de stratégie française qui est
le document ombrel qui porte à la fois
la partie programmation de la loi
énergie de production énergétique et la
partie euh décret de programmation euh
pluriannuelle de l'énergie puisque la
PPE est un décret et les deux euh se
complètent en anenton noir et l'idée
c'est de donner le maximum de visibilité
sur de textes qui ont vocation à à
s'enchaîner de façon à ce que tout le
monde les les voit le calendrier donc
mise à la consultation de cette
stratégie d'ici la fin du mois si tout
va bien la fin la semaine prochaine mais
on on on on fait les les derniers les
dernières passes vous savez que nous
avons également remonté à titre
indicatif et sous réserve de validation
par nos instances de gouvernance un plan
national énergie-climat au niveau EUR
européen donc celui-là sera en ligne on
va être en ligne mais tout ça est est
complètement cohérent avec les travaux
que j'ai déjà mentionné planification
écologique et les travaux des
parlementaires euh pour la loi
énergieclimat
euh nous avons ensuite 6 semaines de
consultation officiell pour porter la
loi 2 semaines de conseil d'État minimum
des vacances de Noël au milieu euh et
donc c'est une présentation qui est
attendue pour fin janvier début février
en conseil des ministres et ensuite
Parlement sur le projet de loi sur la
réforme de notre sûreté nucléaire ce
projet de loi il alors je le
rappelle le projet de loi n'a pas été
examiné enfin en tout cas cet élément là
n'a pas été examiné par le Sénat
puisqu'il a été introduit par amendement
à l'Assemblée nationale il a fait
l'objet d'abord d'une adoption puis
d'une réécriture c'est pour pas réécrire
l'histoire mais le Sénat avait fait
savoir en la personne du rapporteur et
et de la des présidents des commissions
qui qui enfin d'ailleurs c'était la
président de la commission affaires
économiques que
euh cette manière de procéder ne leur
convenait pas plus que elle ne convenait
à l'Assemblée nationale mais disons que
formellement il n'a pas été examiné ici
en revanche effectivement et je salue
cela l'OPEX s'est saisi du sujet et a
rendu un rapport courant juillet c'est
le sénateur pied noir qui l'a rapporté
pour le Sénat et le député fujit qui
font des propositions de réforme de la
Sûreté Nucléaire que nous reprenons
assez largement dans ce projet de loi
qui est aujourd'hui à la consultation et
qui sera présenté au Conseil des
ministres de fin d'année et pareil qui
dans la foulée enchaînera au Parlement
et vous savez plutôt sur ces deux
projets de loi si le Sénat ou
l'Assemblée nationale lequel des deux
seront saisis en premier je n'ai pas
encore le le le calendrier puisque vous
savez qu'il y a
un embouteillage de projets diverses et
variés et que cela est encore en train
d'être précisé je pense que enfin nous
vous avons envoyé le le projet de loi en
état tel qu'il fait l'objet des des
concertations puisque comme c'est une
réponse à l'opeex c'était assez logique
vous en ayez évidemment la teneur dans
son
intégralité alors précision sur le
contenu de de ces
projets la loi de programmation énergie
climat on est bien sur une logique de
prod production énergétique qui reprend
à la fois le cadre européen sur le cadre
européen ce qui est de l'ordre on va
dire du règlement n'est pas retranscrit
parce que c'est c'est du cadre du
règlement ce qui est de l'ordre de je
dirais de l'objectif qu'il faut
atteindre notamment comment on atteint
certains objectifs de production
d'énergie bacarbone donne lieu
effectivement à des des propositions et
c'est ça que nous mettons dans cette loi
il y a également des éléments autour de
la protection du consommateur et
potentiellement de la régulation
de de la régulation de de notre système
tarifaire avec peut-être un une
discussion sur est-ce que c'est c'est
pas et ça je n'ai pas encore le retour
juridique un élément qui relève plutôt
d'un projet loi de finance donc c'est un
point à voir sachant qu'en tout état de
cause il nous faut quand même donner
très vite de la visibilité aux acteurs
donc il faut pas avoir la main qui
tremble sur le calendrier de cette
partie
régulation sur le projet de loi n IRSN
l'objectif est clairement de réunir sous
la même ombrelle l'ensemble des
compétences qui aujourd'hui font la
sûreté nucléaire de notre pays comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans un certain
nombre de pays de renforcer euh ces
compétences vous savez notamment que un
article de loi prévoit de réhausser le
niveau de rémunération euh des acteurs
puisque on constate un décalage par
rapport euh aux rémunération euh des
opérateurs or nous sommes dans un moment
où il y a beaucoup de recrutements qui
se font puisque euh il y a des besoins
et nous ne voulons pas déshabiller la
sûreté nucléaire au dépend des des
Français et donc cette cet exercice est
fait et c'est vraiment dans un objectif
d'indépendance accrue puisque les
acteurs de
l'IRSN bénéficieraient ce qui n'est pas
leur cas aujourd'hui d'un statut
d'autorité administrative indépendante
aujourd'hui ils ont un statut d'pque
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont directement
soumis au pouvoirs politique et et et au
gouvernement et autre objectif donc
renforcement des moyens renforcement de
l'attractivité euh plus grande fluidité
des des procédures et transparence
vis-à-vis du public avec d'autres
méthodologies notamment le fait de
définir des grands sujets de débat
public je pas on peut dire par exemple
par rapport à une actualité récente un
sujet comme la corrosion S contrainte
est un sujet que les assemblées peuvent
désigner comme étant devant faire
l'objet de de point d'étape spécifique
avec consultation du public avant qu'il
y ait une décision prise par le collège
de laasn et qui est nourri par
l'expertise de l'IRSN et de laisn
eu et je je je j'indique aussi que un
certain nombre de sujets sont d'ordre
réglementaire ou d'ordre du règlement
intérieur
du fonctionnement de ces institutions et
donc on mettra pas dans la loi la
question pardon d'être très triviale
mais c'est des questions qui nous
remontent des tickets restaurant du
remboursement des frais de déplacement
ou de l'organisation de tel ou tel
service je pense que la loi la vocation
a rester à un niveau effectivement
principiel et de de dire politiquement
ce qu'on attend de cette
nouvelle de cette nouvelle entité qui
portera la sûreté nucléaire et la
radioprotection
sur maintenant les sujets de financement
vous avez raison Madame la Présidente de
souligner que le plan de vol
d'investissement de DF est absolument
considérable vous mentionnez
sinovospr2 nous avons le grand carénage
il faut y ajouter les réseaux les
réseaux je rappelle kenedis a donné une
trajectoire de l'ordre de 100 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2040 pour rénover les
réseaux vous savez que RTE est en train
de finaliser son plan de vol aussi pour
euh évaluer leurs besoins
complémentaires de réseau et les
interconnexions avec d'autres pays tous
ces éléments sont absolument
indispensables pour permettre de fournir
de l'électricité à tout moment à nos
concitoyens en augmentant notre niveau
de de
résilience et c'est clairement notre
notre objectif et d'une certaine manière
le nouveau nucléaire ne pèse je dis ne
pèse que mais ça pèse quand même que 15
à 20 % des investissements futurs deedf
je vais vous dire la marche à franchir
là aussi en matière d'investissement et
c'est ce qui explique et vous faites le
lien et et vous avez bien
raison également le le modèle de
régulation que nous proposons en
succession de la ren post 2025 la ren ça
se termine fin 2025 en 2026 il faut
donner une trajectoire trajectoire aux
entreprises une trajectoire au ménages
donc pour les ménages c'est un tarif
réglementé qui sera précisé mais qui a
pri prori je dirais ne devrait pas
significativement changer de règle du
jeu techniquement il y aura une autre
façon de le calculer puisquon fait pas
la régulation exactement de la manière
la même manière mais c'est grosso modo
un tarif bleu auquel on est bien habitué
pour les très petites entreprises vous
savez que j'avais porté cette mesure de
d'abandonner la référence au 36 kVA qui
est une spécificité française pour que
toutes les TPE bénéficient du tarif
réglementé parce que c'est parfois un
peu compliqué d'expliquer que parce
qu'on a une ance un peu supérieure bah
on change de catégorie donc là aussi
c'est ce que nous avons annoncé hier
donc ça ça fait partie de de la copie et
puis
pour les les entreprises l'objectif est
d'avoir une très forte incitation à
conclure des contrats de long terme soit
en en les faisant avec un partage de
risque quasiment industriel et donc
c'est une incitation à investir dans
notre dans nos capacités de production
soit en étant sur la possibilité d'avoir
accès
à de la fourniture d'électricité à 5 ans
qui permettra de lisser de réduire la
volatilité des prix et nous mettons en
place
une récupération de la rente qui euh se
mettrait en place au-delà d'un prix de
80 € alors cette rente elle est calculée
sur l'ensemble de la production ire
c'est pas seulement une partie de la
production nucléaire comme l'était la
reine c'est sur l'ensemble
50 % au-delà de de de 80 € alors 78 80 €
ce sont des prix 2022 hein tout ça à
vocation être actualisé comme c'est
logique hein et 110 € à horizon de pour
capter 90 % de la rente ce qui nous
permet d'avoir un bouclier ferme qui est
plus protecteur que l'a été la reine
puisque que laaren avait une efficacité
très forte pour baisser les prix mais
lorsque le marché s'emballer vraiment
elle ne savait pas à bloquer le marché
d'une certaine manière parce que le
volume qui fallait acheter sur le marché
était encore trop important c'est une
responsabilisation des fournisseurs
alternatifs qui n'auront qui devront
travailler à mettre en place une
véritable politique commerciale et pas
seulement répliquer ce que fait EDF
passer une marche commerciale et fermer
leur position tous les soirs dans en
trading et c'est une responsabilisation
d'EDF puisque EDF a calculé ce prix
d'équilibre qui leur permet de supporter
leur investissement futur donc une
trajectoire de plus de 20 milliards
d'euros dans les années qui viennent euh
tout en devant avoir un un un niveau de
d'eficacité euh euh opérationnelle qui
les amène à produire plus de 360 TWh de
nucléaire je rappelle qu'on était à 280
l'année dernière donc c'est pas
l'épaisseur du trait et ça a une vraie
importance pour euh notre résilience
énergétique
euh ce qui fait que pour répondre à
votre question derrière ces
investissements nous embarquons bien le
financement du Grand le financement des
investissements courants le financement
du grand carénage le financement euh
d'une enfin d'une partie assez large des
PR2 sachant que comme l'a dit le
président de DF ce financement doit
aussi être coporté par l'État ça va être
la la deuxème série de travaux que nous
devons mener maintenant parce que que un
projet de PR2 a des caractéristiques
propres de
temps et de risque qui fait que le coût
du financement représente quasiment la
moitié de coût de l'ensemble du projet
et donc si le coût du financement
représente la moitié vous avez intérêt
avoir un coût du financement le plus
faible possible en taux d'intérêt et
celui qui a le meilleur taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui ou qui a le risque le plus
faible ou qui a le coût moyen du capital
le plus faible c'est l'état d'où
l'importance d'avoir une régulation
étatique ensuite le texte que j'ai
obtenu au niveau européen
euh sur la régulation les nouvelles
régulations du marché de l'électricité
pourquoi il est important pour cette
régulation nationale pour trois raisons
la première raison c'est qu'elle traite
à égalité à stricte égalité le nucléaire
et le renouvelable c'était évidemment un
combat important qu'il s'agisse de
l'historique ou du futur la deuxième
raison c'est que les caractéristiques
qui sont établies de CFD euh finalement
vous retrouvez la notion de plafond euh
dans ce que nous faisons on met pas de
plancher mais on met un plafond un
contrat pour différence c'est un
plancher plus un plafond donc on peut
reprendre un certain nombre d'éléments
qui figurent dans cette régulation pour
les besoins propres de la régulation
dont on discute et surtout elle cale les
éléments de régulation future et donc
elle nous permet d'avoir une discussion
avec une référence qui est ce texte pour
la régulation du nouveau nucléaire
j'ajoute aussi qu'elle prévoit euh ça a
l'air d'être compliqué mais en fait
c'est très important des mesures
prudentielles pour les fournisseurs
alternatifs qui évitent l'effet un peu
de entrée sortie je pense que Monsieur
Guay sera euh tout à fait euh favorable
les effets d'entrée et de sortie sur le
marché du des fournisseurs d'électricité
qui ont mis on l'a vu dans les
situations de crise un certain nombre de
clients euh ben qui qui n'ont plus eu de
contrat comme ça du jour au lendemain et
alors que c'était pas vraiment le
meilleur moment pour en conclure hein
donc je pense que c'est important et on
y a beaucoup tenu on a également un
intégrer des éléments de reconnaissance
de la gestion des pics et de la
flexibilité et de la maîtrise
énergétique pour aussi valoriser tous
ceux qui savent effacer et flexibiliser
leur utilisation de l'énergie ça va dans
le sens de la sobriété et là aussi de
plus de résilience c'est un sujet qui
tient beaucoup à cœur au Président
retaillot je vous ai parlé de la reine
donc OK et puis les autres les autres
champs d'action donc sur
l'hydraulique euh de la oui on est sur
la même ligne que le que le président de
DF on a d'ailleurs envoyé une
note une note à la Commission européenne
indiquant notre souhait d'investiguer la
la possibilité d'aller plutôt vers un
régime d'autorisation qu'est-ce qui est
positif dans un régime d'autorisation
c'est que par rapport aux règles du jeu
européenne c'est pas un mouton à CIN
pates comme la concession et donc ça a
beaucoup de valeur parce qu'on a pas
besoin la remettre en concurrence et
qu'une fois qu'on l'a réglé on l'a réglé
pour pour tout euh et qu'ensuite et et
qu'on a des points de référence
européens c'est-à-dire que en Autriche
enfin dans d'autres pays il y a des
autorisations la question qui se posera
c'est cette autorisation suppose en
effet euh un euh comment dire un
transfert d'actifs même s'il y a un
cahier des charges qui peut nous
permettre de reprendre la main comme une
golden share mais un transfert d'actifs
dont le prix sera analysé sous l'angle
de mais n'est-ce pas une aide d'État
faite au bénéfice de tel et tel acteur
qui opèent aujourd'hui des concessions
hydrauliques et bien sûr c'est une
approche qui doit être portée pour
l'ensemble du secteur et donc à ce titre
qui doit être bien mise en ordre parce
qu'il n'y a pas qu'un seul acteur même
si VF c'est un acteur important il y a
aussi les schemes et il y a aussi la CNR
et donc et la CNR qui venait de
renégocier sa concession mais 2040
arrive très très vite donc voilà euh
nous notre objectif en tout cas c'est
d'avancer le plus loin possible sur ce
sur ce sujet là et et d'obtenir ces
possibles accord mais en tout état de
cause on a peut-être d'autres
possibilités juridiques mais c'est
aujourd'hui celle que nous testons
et pour en sortir pardon l'objectif
étant de pouvoir réinvestir lourdement
dans l'hydraulique parce qu' alors s'il
y a un endroit où il y a aucun regret à
investir c'est clairement
l'hydraulique
voilà je crois que j'ai répondu à vos
questions merci beaucoup madame la
ministre donc on va passer à notre
rapporteur pour avis sur les crédits de
la mission énergie dans votre champ de
compétence et puis ensuite
interviendront Fran Menonville pierre
cuipers Jean-Jacques Michot
et voilà et ensuite on ouvrira le débat
à l'ensemble des collègues
daniel Merci prés
ministre je souhaiterais recueillir
votre avis sur certaines évolutions de
crédit énergie de la mission
écologie la première question vous avez
parlé effectivement suite à la question
au questionnement de notre présidente de
la fin de l'arine et du prix en 2026 une
question simple quel sera le prix 2024
quel sera le prix
2025 en premier lieu j'observe que
plusieurs dispositifs de soutien au
consommateurs d'énergie sont de ça des
attentes tout d'abord les mécanis
exceptionnel pour l'électricité et le
gaz et les carburants qui passent de
27,9 milliards à 2,9 milliard d'euros
c'est une diminution drastique pourquoi
ne pas reconduire l'amortisseur
électrique et pourquoi ne prévoir aucune
disposition fiscale ni aucune
disposition budgétaire pour le gaz de
son côté ma prime renve bénéficie de 2,7
milliards d'euros c'est moins que les
recommandations de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur la rénovation
énergétique qui plaidit pour 4 5
milliards les résultats obtenus sont
inférieurs à ceux du crédit d'impôt pour
la transition énergétique ainsi on
dénombre 530000 ménages pour la prime en
2022 contre
1,4 million de ménages pour le cite en
2019 pour un montant moindre plus encore
le recours des propriétaires bailleurs
et les copropriétés reste faible ça
c'est un point qu'on a déjà évoqué
ensemble mais ça se confirme en effet
27000 prime ont été attribué à des
propriétaires bailleurs et 500 à des
copropriétés en 2023 nous avons
l'impression que le gouvernement n'a pas
encore trouvé le moyen de massifier
cette prime qu'en pensez-vous enfin le
chèque énergie stagne avec 900 millions
d'euros les dispositifs exceptionnel
pour le fi ou le bois ne sont pas
reconduits et la question simple
entendez-vous corriger le tir ou pas sur
ces deux secteurs en second lieu je
constate que plusieurs investissements
en faveur de la transition tiqu sont en
desessa des engagements tout d'abord
aucun crédit n'est prévu pour le fond de
revitalisation des territoires ni pour
le fond d'accompagnement social des
salariés destinés notamment à
accompagner les fermetures de centrales
à charbon or ces dispositifs sont issus
de l'engagement pris par le gouvernement
lors de l'examen de la loi énergie
climat en 2019 et notamment à
l'initiative du Sénat plus encore les
charges de service publics de l'énergie
qui s entendent les dispositifs de
soutien aux énergies renouvlables son
incertaines pour la 2e année consécutive
elle pourrait être négative avec 2,7
milliards à quoi serviront les recettes
pour perçu par l'État à ce titre une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel du
26 octobre 2023 invalidé le plafonnement
des compléments de rénumération pour
2023 ce qui représenterait un manque à
gagner de 4 milliards selon la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
confirmez-vous ce montant le dispositif
de substitution aujourd'hui proposé par
le gouver permet-il d'éviter ce manque à
gagner et enfin nous souhaiterions
abonder
le le compte d'affectation spéciale le
cas fcé ce compte présente un excédent
de 17 million de recettes qui est
rétrocédé au budget général c'est une
anomalie qu'en
pensez-vous merci Daniel Fran Menonville
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes questions porteront
davantage sur sur l'accélération la loi
d'accélération donc des énergies
renouvelables du 10 mars
2023 tout d'abord plusieurs dispositifs
de soutien budgétaire ou fiscaux
attendent pour leur mise en œuvre une
notification auprès de la Commission
européenne je pense notamment à la prise
en compte des appels d'offre de la
contribution territoriale au partage de
la valeur des installation agrivoltaïqu
des communautés énergétiques ainsi
qu'aux sociétés d'approvisionnement à
long terme où on sens ces notifications
il y a d'autres dispositifs plus y
anciens qui sont qui font l'objet
d'échange avec la Commission européenne
je pense notamment en particulier au
soutien à la production d'hydrogène
produit par électrolyse issu de la loi
énergie climat donc de 2019 et aux
effacements de consommation issu de la
loi transition énergétique de 2015 où on
sont ces échanges madame la ministre par
ailleurs plusieurs dispositifs réglement
pose des difficultés
d'application le premier le projet de
cahier des charges prévu pour le soutien
à l'hydrogène produit par électrolyse le
seuil de 30 mW prévu exclut un grand
nombre de projets locaux sur no nos
territoires ne faudrait-il pas le
réviser réviser ce seuil le deuxième est
le projet de décret pour l'application à
l'hydroélectricité de la raison
impératif d'intérêt public majeur le
seuil de 150 MW envisagé laisse de côté
des projets hydroélectriques de
territoire là aussi ne devrait-on pas
ajouter ajuster donc également ce seuil
le troisième est le projet de décret
fixant les fixant les friches sur
lesquelles est autorisé l'installation
d'ouvrage de production solaire seul 25
sites seraient retenus le confirmez-vous
et enfin la dernière question concerne
les la publication et la finalisation
des décrets d'application concernant
l'agrivol voltaïsme sachant qu'ils sont
très attendus sur les territoires car
l'activisme s'opère sur les territoires
par les développeurs nous avons
absolument besoin de ces décrets pour
réguler et encadrer des projets vertueux
sur les territoires madame la ministre
Pierre cupers oui merci Madame la
présidence madame la ministre je ma
question porte sur la future loi sur la
programmation et la régulation
énergétique alors pouvez-vous nous
indiquer les objectifs du gouvernement
envisager d'ici 30 en matière d'énergie
nucléaire mais aussi d'électricité de
gaz et de chaleur
renouvelable sachant que vous avez
annoncé une multiplication par 2 voire
par 3 du solaire et une augmentation de
2 Gow par rang de l'éolien pour le
solaire je constate votre annonce que
votre annonce est inférieure que ce que
prévoit le réseau de transport
électricité qui propose une
multiplication par 4 voire par 5 pour
l'éolien votre annonce est supérieur à
ce que prévoit RTE qui envisage une
augmentation de 0,7 à
1,5 pouvez-vous nous expliquer ces
différence ma deuxème question c'est
qu'au Sénat nous avons soutenu des
objectifs de 27,5 Gow d'hydroélectricité
soutenu également 680000 tonnes de
production d'hydrogène également 80 tawh
pour la production de biogaz et 300 TWh
pour celle de chaleur renouvelable or
les annonces du gouvernement sont peu
dissertes sur ces autres sources
d'énergie
décarboné qui nous semble les
compléments essentiels des énergies
solaires éoliennees et nucléaire alors
madame la ministre reprendrez-vous ces
objectifs Jean-Jacques Michot
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous en avez déjà un peu parlé
mais je souhaiterais vous interroger sur
le rapport de la mission transpartisan
nucléaire et hydrogène l'urgence d'AV
d'agir que nous avons réalisé en Ju
juillet 2022 avec mon mes collègues
Daniel grimier et Jean-Pierre Moga parmi
nos propositions nous avons appelé à
garantir à l'énergie à l'hydrogène
nucléaire une complète neutralité
technologique dans le cadre des textes
européens la taxonomie énergie verte
européenne la directive sur les énergies
renouvelables ou le règlement sur la
réforme du marché de
l'électricité les compromis trouvés
s'agissant de l'inclusion de l' Energie
nucléaire à la taxonomie et au règlement
de l'hydrogène nucléaire à la directive
vous semble-t-il suffisant pour
permettre la relance de l'énergie
nucléaire et le développement de
l'hydrogène nucléaire de plus
envisagez-vous de négocier un contrat
pour différence pour le financement du
nouveau nucléaire ou du nucléaire
existant et si oui quells sont les
contreparties à attendre de la part de
la Commission européenne enfin
entendez-vous intégrer les compromis
négociés à l'échelon européen au projet
de loi annoncé sur la programmation et
la rénovation énergétique comme l'a
relevé le PDG du groupe EDF devant notre
commission la semaine dernière il s'agit
d'une boîte à outils entre guillemets
devant encore être appliqué pour notre
part si nous saluons les avancées
réalisées il nous semble que les
conditions européennes fixées sont
encore ambigues et restrictive et que
les dispositions nationales attendent
une précision et une
sécurisation merci pour Fabien Guay pour
terminer avant que vous nous répondiez à
ces questions madame la ministre
Fabien merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre avant d' venir à laarine
permettez-moi un mot sur la fusion IRSN
ASN ça les communistes ils ont toujours
été pour le nucléaire mais à deux
conditions
la première c'est un haut niveau de
Sécur de sécurité de
sûreté et ce qui va avec la transparence
pour les populations et la deuxième
question c'est un haut niveau de statut
pour les salariés et donc je vous le dis
madame la
ministre je veux pas polémiquer avec
vous mais vous avez dit il y a un débat
avec qui me remonte sur lestickets
restaurant euh je je vous dis ça je sais
que vous recevez l'intersyndicale
régulièrement vous l'avez déjà fait vous
allez le refaire jeudi prochain moi
aussi je discute avec eux les débats
pour l'instant il non mais je vous dis
ça il porte pas sur les tickets
restaurant quoi alors dans votre dans
votre et je remercie madame
D'Agostini qui j'ai changé dans votre
projet de loi mais non mais on peut le
dire c'est pas grave faut faut d' foir
des fois remercier les les
collaborateurs les collaboratrices je le
dis avec plaisir non mais je dis ça
parce que il y a des choses dedans mais
il en manque pour l'instant madame la
ministre par
exemple pour les ceux qui vont être dans
la direction de l'expertise nucléaire de
défense et sur la dosiométrie il y a des
vraies questions autour du statut de
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont devenir ils seront
pas dans la future entité voyez donc
voilà je vous dis ça prenons le le débat
dans dans le bon sens d'entré et je
pense que la question autour des
salariés de leur avenir de l'avenir de
certains sites va peser aussi sur le le
bon fonctionnement de de cette fusion
mais je sais que vous le savez deuxème
chose j'en viens maintenant à mon
dossier sur sur sur l'AREN vous venez de
nous présenter la réforme de DF il y
aura beaucoup de questions autour de
ça bon on n'est pas d'accord mais parce
que moi je considère que l'énergie doit
être sortie du secteur marchand donc je
le dis comme ça si on est dans votre
vision qui est entendable respectable et
cetera c'est un débat politique je pense
que c'est une bonne réforme mais moi je
la combats parce que je je ne suis pas
d'accord mais donc vous inventez rien
mais quand je dis ça les contrats pour
différence voilà c'est c'est l'ancien
PDG de DF Quié ça pour le nucléaire
londonier en fait on reprend des choses
mais c'est pas grave bon pas toujours
marché euh moi j'ai j'ai j'ai beaucoup
de questions je pense que ça va apporter
de la stabilité pour les entreprises il
y a une question quand même autour des
tarifs réglementés hein qui n'est pas
neutre moi je je je me pose deux
questions autour de ça les 70 € est-ce
que ça va être assez pour couvrir coût
de production les 50 milliards
d'investissements pour le grand carénage
les 50 milliards pour les 6pr et les 65
milliards de dett c'estàd là il y a 165
milliards voyez je suis pas sûr que les
70 € et donc ce qui me fait craindre que
on revienne dans quelques temps et nous
dire EDF n'y arrive pas parce je vois
qu'en plus vous avez dit c'est une bonne
réforme vous et Bruno le ma
et on dit en disant EDF maintenant doit
avoir les moyens d'agir et on va lui
demander de rendre des comptes et je
pense que ça ne suffira pas et je pense
qu'on reviendra ici nous expliquer que
ça ne marche pas et que donc il faut
revenir un projetcul 2 c'est-à-dire de
de découpe et sur
l'arène alors vous avez répondu sur la
partie prudentielle qu'on avait fait
avec madame la Présidente Dominique
Estrosi mais on a une vraie question moi
je comprends pas bien le système
au-dessus de 110 € qui revient au
consommateur et consommatrice et j'en
viens sur la mission qu'on nous avemmené
avec Dominique pardon madame la
Présidente euh excusez-moi madame la
Présidente
euh il y a 1 milliard 6 de CP1 CP2 qui
on été qui on été frappé on nous a dit
ça va revenir au consommateur et on a
toujours pas compris
toujours pas compris comment ça revient
au consommateur et là on nous redit
pareil au-dessus de 110 € l'état prendra
ça reviendra au consommateur il faut
bien qu'on nous explique le mécanisme là
parce que déjà on le comprend pas bien
aujourd'hui c'est assez opaque en
réalité ça va revenir au fournisseur
alternatif bah si non le CP1 CP2 ah
ouais ouais ou d'accord mais on nous a
expliquer que ça rit au consommateur
donc les gens qui payent de l'amende
vont se redistribuer l'amende ça c'est
quand même un truc si les gens savaient
ça ça serait un scandale donc si si on
pouvait bien nous expliquer le système
de 2026 que ça revienne pas comme ça je
je pense que c'est mieux et dernière
chose entre aujourd'hui et
2026 il y a 3 ans enfin 2 ans et demi 2
ans 2 ans 2 ans 2 ans et demi allez bon
c'est mon côté un peu un peu voilà
euh je pense qu'on peut pas rester dans
le même système là enfin en tout cas il
faut mettre des un certain nombre de
verrou que nous avons identifié en avait
mais enfin vous voyez parce que la
facture électrique 25 % pour les les
gens cette année vous annoncez 10 % si
ça continue à vous allez pouvoir me dire
que c'est faux voilà 10 % en février ça
peut pas continuer à Flammer comme ça
quand même pour un certain nombre de
ménages de commerçant une petite
entreprise voilà je vous remercie voilà
madame la ministre je vous propose de
répondre à l'ensemble de ces questions
très précises et
nombreuses
sur donc dans les médias je je rappelle
qu'il y aura une conférence sur les prix
de l'énergie euh qui sera organisée euh
pour les responsables enfin les
euh les présidents de groupe ou toute
personne qui souhaiteraiit désigner au
sein de leur groupe le 28 novembre
prochain je crois que c'est de 16h30 à
18h30 et qui baléra les sujets gaz
électricité carburant à la demande d'un
président de groupe euh du de
l'Assemblée nationale mais ça nous a
paraît utile de l'élargir à à tout le
monde ainsi qu'au présidents
d'association toute personne qu'il
souhaiterait qu'il souhaiterait désigner
pour être très pratico pratique les prix
2024 on maintient le bouclier
énergétique et donc la creux
évaluera en début d'année prochaine le
niveau de tarif régulé tel qui résulte
de ces calculs habituel avec intégrant
le prix du marché et ce que nous avons
dit avec Bruno le ma c'est qu' tout
cause si ce chiffre devait être
supérieur à 10 % nous ne n'augmenterions
pas de plus de 10 %. la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce chiffre pour le moment
et je l'année n'est pas terminée n'est
pas supérieur à 10 %. donc voilà ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'au 1er février
2024 le fleuve a l'air de rentrer dans
son lit je suis prudente nous avons une
situation géopolitique qui est
euh nu enfin contrasté pour dire le
moins donc il faut être prudent mais
néanmoins c'est ça que ça veut dire
c'est ça qu'on dit avec Bruno Le Maire
sur le prix
2025 la mécanique qui s'applique est
similaire et en toutt de cause la
prévision alors encore une fois avec
Moutte cave Hâ puisque on a pu constater
que quand vous avez des chocs majeurs
exogènes sur les marchés les prix
pouvaient s'en s'envoler mais pour le
moment nous n'avons pas de signaux qui
vont dans ce sens et je crois nous avons
tous pu constater et nous avons tous des
éléments très clairs sur comment les
crises se forment et quels sont les
meilleurs les meilleurs outils pour y
répondre et les enfin tout ce qui a été
fait l'année dernière avec le bouclier
énergétique les systèmes d'information
des différents fournisseurs d'énergie
pour le mettre automatiquement enfin
l'adaptation des systèmes d'information
pour le mettre automatiquement sur les
factures fait que si vraiment en 24 et
en 25 on devait avoir faire face à une
nouvelle flambée des prix on est équipé
pour agir voilà ce que je peux vous dire
mais pour le moment ce n'est pas ce que
nous disent ce que nous disent les
marchés ce n'est pas ce que nous disent
les production ce n'est pas ce que que
nous connaissons de l'état de la
situation en Europe et et en France même
chose d'ailleurs pour le gaz vous avez
pu le constater le prix du enfin là
aussi pourquoi le bouclier gaz a été
enlevé tout simplement parce que
naturellement le prix du gaz est de
repasser en dessous du prix de
protection du bouclier gaz et donc
mécaniquement il n'est plus op opérant
voilà c'est ématique s'agissant et donc
c'est ça qui explique les montants aussi
c'est-à-dire c'est assez mécanique dès
lors que les prix sur les marchés de
gros hein redescendent au niveau des
boucliers que nous avons fixé qui a un
plafonnement du prix pour les
particuliers bah de le bouclier se
désactive
naturellement sur la question de de ma
prime renove je l'ai dit
le l'augmentation du budget est
absolument massive ça c'est le premier
point et pour être honnête hê ma
préoccupation de ministre de l'énergie
et du climat et plus va-t-on bien les
dépenser et va-t-on tous les dépenser
que en a-t-on assez à dépenser
aujourd'hui c'est ça à la deuxième
question sur l'efficacité du cete je
crois qu'il y a eu beaucoup de rapport
assez clair qui disaient ce système
n'est pas efficace en terme de baisse
des émissions de CO2 et par ailleurs
cible les ménages les plus riche ce qui
est pas tout à fait l'objectif me
semble-t-il d'une transition écologique
et
socialement juste donc le système de ma
prime renve il cible d'abord les ménages
les plus modestes à 66 % là où à 80 %
c'était les ménages les moins modestes
qui étaient ciblés pour le cite donc on
a quand même renversé la vapeur et je
rappelle qu'en matière de rénovation
thermique c'était
70000 dans la dernière année du du du
quininand on est aujourd'hui vous
mentionnez 530000 600000 700000 bon on a
fait des chiffres c'est une
multiplication par 10 donc je je partage
pas l'analyse en revanche
la question des propriétaires bailleur
c'est une très bonne question et il y a
des marges de progrès sur lequel il faut
travailler il y a des propositions
d'ailleurs qui ont été faites en
différents
rapports et comment massifier si tout le
travail que nous voulons faire aussi
pour faciliter fluidifier le parcours
des propriétaire plusieurs choses pour
cela l'accompagnateur renove
l'accompagnateur renove c'est une
pration
qui représente 2000 € donc c'est pas
rien elle est absolument gratuite pour
les revenus fiscales de référence les
plus modestes elle est très assez bien
comment dire subventionné pour les
revenus fiscal de référence 3 et 4 et
c'est quelqu'un qui vous aide à monter
votre dossier administratif technique et
financier donc ça c'est probablement un
vrai élément de
changement pour le parcours euh le
deuxième élément c'est l'avance par
l'ANA du financement pour les plus
modestes donc avoir une avance c'est
quand même assez utile puisqu'on a vous
l'avez mentionné beaucoup vous avez ce
reste à charge qui fait que c'est un
frein à l'engagement des travaux là où
on a une avance pour aller plus loin il
y a les coptz sur les coptz on sait tous
que le nombre d'unités distribué n'est
pas satisfaisante il faut à la fois
pousser les banques à distribuer cet
outil c'est parce qu'on a tous des gens
qui nous parlent que souvent c'est pas
la première offre qu'on leur fait quand
ils vont voir des banques donc il y a
cette question de distribution il y a
aussi une question je pense qu'il faut
l'aborder froidement de nos propres
règles prudentielles au niveau des
banques l'analyse de risque d'un ménage
dont ni enfin vous avez pas de revenus
réguliers en CDI peut amener la banque à
dire ce risque est trop élevé donc je ne
donne pas le prêt sauf qu'il se trouve
que c'est souvent les personnes
qu'on cherche à soutenir donc à un
moment va falloir craquer ce ce léger
yatus cognitif auquel nous faisons nous
faisons face d'où le préavance
rénovation qui est assez malin puisqueen
fait c'est une avance sur des opérations
futures de revente de mutation et là
pour le coup a priori il y a la matière
fiscale pour le faire à condition que le
bien simpliier ai et il faut le
simplifier à condition que le bien soit
pas déjà un collatéral d'un prêt estce
que vous pouvez pas mettre deux fois sur
l'actif donc ce que nous faisons aussi
c'est que nous allons coupler le nous
allons revenir à un couplage C2E MapR
brenov pour avoir un seul guichet je
pense que ça tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire que ça facilitera la vie de de
pas multiplier les
choses et
puis nous ouais ça je pense qu'on a pas
besoin de le dire propriété bailleurs
mais il y a la question des copropriétés
aussi alors les copropriétés excellente
question là aussi il va avoir vous savez
que Patrice fergrit travaille sur un
projet de loi autour du
logement dégradé et des
copropriétés sa vocation à être abordée
dans dans le cadre de de de cette de ce
projet de loi et effectivement avec la
question de comment fait-on prendre une
décision une copropriété comment
peut-elle porter les financements
comment euh qui s'en dette
qui est la contrepartie euh et
comment met-on en place des dispositifs
qui permettent de sécuriser les
différentes parties prenantes de la
copropriété pour aller vite et prendre
vite des décisions effectivement sujet
relativement complexe moi le dernier
point sur lequel je souhaite qu'on
avance et je sais que Christophe Béchu
est sur la même ligne que moi c'est
d'avoir une
contractualisation euh du travail avec
les collectivités locales il y a un
certain nombre de collectivités locales
EPCI
ou communes qui sont très actifes sur la
rénovation thermique qui ont également
leurs propres aides leurs propres
guichet sur lequel il faut vraiment
ponter les choses et quelque part on
serait tout à fait prêt à déléguer les
enveloppes sur la base d'un contrat en
disant
euh et et quitte à avoir une approche
extraordinairement je dirais dirigie
c'est-à-dire on fait quartier par
quartier rue par eux on va voir les gens
on fait du porte à porte et je pense que
il y a qu'une commune qui peut enfin il
y a que des des personnes qui relèvent
d'un service municipal ou
d'intercommunalité qui peut faire ça
parce queil y a tellement d'incitations
de porteaportte de gens qui se prévut
d'être l'État et cetera qu'il faut
connaître les gens confiance il y a une
notion de confiance qui est essentielle
par contre cibler des quartiers dont on
sait que le bâtir par construction il
date de telle année que il a pas été
bien fait que il y a une chance assez
forte qu'on est sans avoir les DPE en
main mais qu'on est sur du G ou du f ça
on peut faire et avoir des app proche
vraiment quartier par quartier où vous
avez euh et c'est fait hein vous je
discutais avec Virginie carolo il y a
pas si longtemps avec avec la Bretagne
avec Louis ginra ils ont tous très envie
d'avancer et il y a des expérimentations
qui montrent que quartier par quartier
ça avance mais ça veut dire que vous
avez des contrats de jeunes qui vont
faire ce fameux porte- à porte
qu'ensuite vous avez un rendez-vous qui
est donné à la structure de conseil
qu'ensuite vous avez quelqu'un qui passe
pour aller faire le tour du logement et
regarder ce qu'il faut isoler en
priorité avant que de changer la
chaudière et c'est tous ces éléments là
qu'il faut avancer effectivement c'est
du très lourd si on veut bien utiliser
l'argent public mais je vous le redis
nous on est tout à fait prêt à
travailler sur ça euh sur la CSPE
euh les recettes c'est la mécanique de
la prévision des prix donc c'est un
mécanisme d'ajustement sur les
reversements des énergies renouvelables
je dirais que la bonne nouvelle c'est
que ça montre que les énergies
renouvelables sont compétitives ça veut
dire que l'investissement que nous avons
fait que les gouvernements successifs
ont fait d'ailleurs ces 20 dernières
années portent leur fruit aujourd'hui
sur le plafonnement du complément de
rémunération et la décision du conseil
constitutionnal vous avez dû le voir il
y a eu un un amendement qui sera porté
ou qui est porté qui a été portter pour
tirer le enfin prendre acte de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel et
et reproposer un système qui fonctionne
et je pense que c'est très important
pour le budget sur l'utilisation des
recettes c'est clairement des recettes
qui ont été mises au travail pour
financer le plafonnement le le bouclier
énergétique au fond ce que nous avons
organisé de manière très frustre c'est
un bouclier c'est un CFD c'est-à-dire
que au-delà d'un prix qui était jugé
comme un prix correct on est allé
récupérer la rente inframarginale et on
est allé la redonner dans le cadre du
bouclier au français ça revient
exactement à ça que ce soit la crime euh
ou le déplafonnement
de la restitution de la CSPE c'est le
complément par rapport au marché du prix
qui a été redonné au travers des
mécanismes de bouclier donc la logique
est au fond
assez assez
attendue sur le cas je me permettrai de
revenir vers vous parce que là je suis
un peu en capacité de vous répondre de
manière
automatique sur le la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables
euh on a effectivement
une notification à à la commission sur
le partage de la valeur car elle est
assimilée à une aide d'État le sujet
c'est que nous avons d'abord travaillé
avec les élus locaux à faire les
associations d'élus et aussi des députés
et des sénateurs à avoir des
propositions sur lesifire parce que tout
est articulé l'IFER est articulé au
partage de la valeur parceque c'est deux
manières de faire revenir les bénéfices
des projets d'énergie renouvelable dans
le budget des collectivités locales donc
bouger l'un sans intégrer les évolutions
de l'autre ne fait pas de sens et après
avoir stabilisé ça nous sommes euh en en
consolidation pour faire une saisie de
la Commission européenne ça c'est le le
premier point
euh sur la question de euh donc
l'effacement la saisine est en cours je
là j'attends plutôt la Commission
européenne sur l'hydrogène même chose
sur les décrets ou les dispositifs de
réglementair de mise en œuvre de la loi
sur la partie planification énergétique
et zone d'accélération je le rappelle il
y a pas besoin de texte je pu l'entendre
sur le terrain il n'y a pas besoin de
texte tout est dans la loi et c'est une
texte application directe et tout le
enfin tout ce qui était attendu de
l'État notamment la mise à disposition
des documents a été fait au mois de juin
et j'ai écrit personnellement à tous les
maires et tous les présidents
d'intercommunalité pour leur dire que du
coup la date limite était fixée au 31
décembre pour remonter les zones
d'accélération mais que bien entendu on
avait bien compris que tout le monde
n'était pas sur la même ligne de départ
et que du coup ce n'était pas non plus
une date coupprès que l'enjeu c'était de
pouvoir faire en sorte que ceux qui
étaient en avance et on a déjà des
délibérations qui arrivent puissent
avancer et ceux qui avaient besoin d'un
peu plus de temps puissent continuer à
travailler l'idée c'est surtout qu'il
faut pas lever le crayon parce que je
sais pas pas tenir à date du 31 décembre
donc on se reparle l'année Pr c'est pas
ça qu'on veut c'est qu'on veut que il y
a ceux qui livreront leurs résultat au
31 décembre ceux qui seront au 15
janvier ceux qui seront au 31 janvier et
que voilà et tout ça prendra le temps
qu'il faudra mais en tout état de cause
on a intérêt à ce que ceux qui sont en
avance puissent bénéficier de tout de
suite des avantages de la loi euh sur
le alors le cahier des charge sur
l'hydrogène sauf erreur de ma part il
est en
consultation donc ça fait partie des
sujets qui qui remonte et qu'on
analysera sur le seuil de la petite
hydro pour la
reconnaissance d'un turé public majeur
le seuil qui a été alors moi je vais
être très CLA c'est un débat
entre les experts de la biodiversité
c'est un débat des experts de la
biodiversité on va plutôt le dire comme
ça c'est-à-dire que l'enjeu énergétique
au niveau national sur la petite hydro
entre 150 MW 150 kW 1 MW 3 MW c'est
l'épaisseur du trait sur notre
production
nationale donc moi j'ai dit à mes
collègues qui ont en charge la
biodiversité sur un tel sujet la
décision elle est plutôt de votre côté
parce que c'est vous qui portez ce
sujet-là qui avait d'un côté des
collectivités locales qui vous
interpellent en disant moi j'ai besoin
localement pour mes besoins locaux ce
qui est d'une autre nature que nationaux
d'avoir des petites hydrolienes et
d'autres qui leur répondent euh la
analyse de biodiversité de tel et tel
expert en biodiversité c'est que ces
projets
sont impactants pour la biodiversité les
les passes à poissons et cetera et que
c'est pas une bonne idée de mettre des
seuils aussi bas et ce débat là il est
en train de dérouler donc on a transmis
un projet à 3 MW il est en train de se
dérouler notamment dans le cadre du
Conseil national dans la transition
énergétique et je dirais que on en
tirera les les conclusions mais c'est
comme ça que que je souhaite le
présenter c'est-à-dire que je considère
qu'il est légitime que la position du
ministère de la transition énergétique
soit en mode mineur par rapport à un
sujet qui est grosso modo pas
structurant vu de ma fenêtre alors qu'il
est important pour les collectivités
locales et la biodiversité et que c'est
là que doit se faire l'arbitrage euh et
j'ai toute confiance pour qu'on trouve
le bon
arbitrage sur les 25 sites pour le
photovoltaïque sur site dégradé c'est
vraiment une analyse site par site en
fonction des remontées moi ce qui me
paraît important c'est de sortir le
premier décret s'il y en a d'autres
c'est très bien mais je rappelle que ces
sites ont un certain nombre de
caractéristique à remplir et qu'il faut
donc prouver qu'il les remplissent sur
les décrets agrovoltaïsme alors là c'est
un sujet
double on est à la fin du process de
préparation je peux vous dire qu'on a
énormément travaillé
avec
les les
associations enfin les les les
fédérations d'agriculteur euh l'inraer
euh sortir des études techniques et
cetera pour essayer de trouver la bonne
façon de formuler ce ce décret je
signale d'ailleurs qu'il y a parfois on
prête à l'inrae des études qui ne sont
pas en fait endossées par l'inrae qui
qui donneent des chiffres qui sont faux
sur la le taux de couverture et la perte
de rendement puisque moi je le redis
l'objectif de la GR de l'agrivoltaïsme
ce n'est pas de mettre en danger la
souveraineté de notre pays et donc ça ne
doit pas don donner lieu à des pays on
perd de du rendement agricole c'est
contraire à l'esprit de la loi et c'est
contraire pour le coup si j'ai quand
même une ligne rouge c'est que moi j'ai
enfin voilà il a le législateur à
trancher on applique ce que dit le
législateur et donc de ce point de
vue-là euh je pense qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui sur des équilibres qui sont
de bon de bon niveau un bon compromis
qui nous permettra donc là encore on
doit rentrer dans les toutes les
consultations euh
obligatoire et moi je ferai des annonces
à la fin du mois de
novembre ce qui fera une sortie du
décret fin de l'année début d'année
prochaine à peu près dans ces eau là et
avec les Chambres d'agriculture la f les
jeunes agriculteurs ont continue à
échanger pour faire en sorte aussi que
localement tout cela atterrisse il y a
un éléphant dans la
pièce c'est le partage de la valeur qui
est pas un sujet de la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables qui est un
sujet de l'équilibre des beau ruraux et
de comment on adapte C cette logique qui
est issu quand même de de 70
ans de politique agricole à un fait
nouveau qui est l'agrivoltaïisme et ça
c'est un sujet sur lequel là aussi on a
beaucoup échangé avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc fen et sur lequel je
pense qu' y a des propositions de nature
législative et alors c'est peut-être un
objet de PPL c'est peut-être un objet
mais
pardon sauf si vous prévoyez comme dans
le statut du fermage une sorte de
fermage agrivoltaïque c'est-à-dire qui
dit en gros comment je désintéresse le
propriétaire du sujet vous voyez c'est
c'est ça un peu le mais vous avez raison
c'est difficile en fait la loi elle est
très bien écrite elle met ceinture
bretelle parachute on n pas le droit de
mettre du PV au sol sur une terre
agricole
elle prévoit une définition très précise
de l'agrivoltaïsme et cetera le problème
on a tous compris l'éléphant dans la
pièce c'est que
entre un bail rural à quelques centaines
d'euros de l'hctare et un terrain
agrivoltaïque à quelques milliers de
l'hctare à un moment ça vous rend
créatif sur l'interprétation de la
loi voilà et c'est ça qui c'est ça et
c'est sur ça que certains élus locaux
bloquent et
certains représentant d'agriculture bloc
et dans d'autrees côté vous avez aussi
des projets qui fonctionnent très bien
je pense en viticulture en arboriculture
où le sujet est pas tout à fait le même
en terme parce que vous allez pas
démonter les arbres et la V et les
vignes mais c'est du plus et
effectivement où vous avez des demandes
donc moi j'ai des présidents de région
qui bloquent complètement des présidents
de région qui me disent mais qu'est-ce
que vous fichez il faut sortir le décret
et j'ai rarement eu un sujet en 5 an
d'expérience de ministre où j'ai un
grand écart comme ça et qui est pas un
grand écart
entre ensemble d'acteurs homogènes mais
qui est un grand écart vraiment de
perception c'est deux présidents de
région sont pas du tout sur la même
ligne deux agriculteurs qui sont pas du
tout sur la même ligne deux J qui sont
pas du tout sur la même ligne donc ça
veut dire que quelque part il y a un
sujet à reprendre je pense que ce sujet
là l'éléphant dans la pièce c'est le
partage de la valeur c'est dire que les
deux ont raison parce qu'on a pas traité
le sujet et que c'est pas les les
énergies renouvelables le sujet c'est le
partage de la valeur donc ça ça va être
effectivement un travail qu'on doit
prendre collectivement et je dirais qui
intéresse plus enfin qui nous intéresse
Marc Phen au moins
euh sur les objectifs gouvernementaux
2030- 2035 donc je crois que c'est
disponible assez facilement puisque vous
le savez ça figure dans la planification
écologique ça on a repris très largement
les
propositions des groupe de travail
parlementaire association d'élu pour la
alpec donc je vais vous dire l'état de
de la question et je vais préciser une
chose nos objectifs sont complètement
alignés avec ceux de RTE donc quand je
dis il y a des écarts avec RTE c'est pas
vrai ils sont totalement aligné avec ces
de RTE puis qu'on le on leur a refait en
fait on fait des interactions
permanentes et on refait tourner les
modélisations donc je vous le dis c'est
doublement du rythme de de déploiement
du solaire maintien maintien pas
accélération du rythme de l'éolien
maintien du du rythme de
l'éolien doublement du rythme de
déploiement du biogaz euh et pareil sur
la chaleur renouvelable euh 10
GW qui soit mis aux gens cher ou en tout
cas en en attribution pour l'année 2025
en éolien marin et sur et donc sur
l'hydraulique la sécurité qu'on prend
avec RTE c'est de dire comme nous avons
comme le dérèglement climatique va
probablement diminuer notre potentiel
hydraulique dans des proportions que
nous avons du mal à prévoir nous faisons
tous les investissements dans
l'hydraulique mais nous ne prenons nous
ne considérons pas comme acquis
l'augmentation du potentiel de
l'hydraulique donc nous les finançons
mais nous disons pas que ça va venir en
suppément de notre mix énergétique nous
disons que c'est c'est une réserve c'est
une sécurité si on en fait plus c'est
formidable mais il faut déjà sauver
l'hydraulique qui existe en faisant les
investissements de monté de puissance
c'est ça et c'est la logique de RTE
parce que il y a la et c'est très
important et politiquement l'en jeu
c'est on finance l'hydraulique mais il y
a la technique ou le physique ou la
science qui vous dit si vous mettez
toutes vos billes dans l'hydraulique et
que vous pensez que ça va augmenter de 7
GW c'est très sypathique il faut juste
faire passer le dérèglement climatique
dessus et si vous avez zéro à l'arrivée
vous allez avoir une
impasse
sur ensuite les rythmes par rapport à
différents chiffres qui peuvent circuler
euh la direction que nous prenons et moi
je l'ai dit à la filière photovoltique
c'est que je n'ai aucun problème à
introduire dans la loi ou dans le
système quelque chose qui dit si on
dépasse les objectifs
annualiser les premières et deè années
on réhausse automatiquement les
objectifs c'est-à-dire un peu des effets
de cliqué mais je crois qu'il est
important parce que moi je veux bien
qu'on double le rythme de photovoltaïque
c'est formidable puis on le triple mais
j'aimerais juste faire mes objectifs je
suis désolé je suis un peu les deux
pieds pas dans les mêmes sabots je j'ai
quand même envie qu'on les fasse et donc
je préfère avoir un pied de pilote en
disant faut que tout le monde tire vers
le haut et puis dès qu'il y en a un qui
tire plus vite que les autres on
réajuste alors j'ai pas encore trouvé la
formulation juridique pour ça mais je
pense que c'est la bonne manière de
faire et si ça bloque sur un
développement on réhausse de l'autre
côté et en
fait depuis un an que je travaille sur
ce sujet je nous invite à être
extraordinairement
agile pour être capable de dire on est
en décalage sur la sobriété on en remet
une couche sur tel autre système en fait
il va falloir piloter comme ça tout le
temps et je pense que ça méritera un
rapport au Parlement ou une audition ou
quelque chose tous les ans tous les ans
si on veut vraiment battre la mesure
c'est tous les ans qu'il faut y passer
je je ça fait du travail en plus pour
nous mais je pense que c'est important
qu'on partage les objectifs et avec la
maîtrise énergétique d' enfin la baisse
de la consommation d'énergie et
l'augmentation de la production de
l'autre sur le biogaz moi j'aimerais
faire plus j'ai un vrai problème de
biomasse ça ne boucle
pas donc là encore si vous voulez je
prends un niveau d'équilibre entre
l'engagement du monde agricole et
forestier de dire je vous sors autant de
biomasse en plus et ma capacité à
transformer ça en biogaz sachant que par
ailleurs il y a le biocarburant enfin
que dans la biomasse o on dit on a des
problèmes il faut bien Serrier la biogaz
gazeuse la biogaz solide et le pardon la
biomasse gazeuse la biomasse solide et
la biomasse liquide euh voilà donc c'est
et sur le nucléaire 2030 de choses
l'augmentation de notre productible
nucléaire par une meilleure performance
c'est là où on arrive au 360 TWh on
ajoute d'ailleurs dans ça 10 TWh de
flamandville et on pousse EDF et on va
soutenir les investissements dans le
changement de puissance notamment sur
les réacteurs 900 m wat où on peut aller
chercher chez eux 5 % de production en
plus mais par des investissements
complémentaires donc c'est pas juste
l'excellence opérationnelle c'est des
investissements complémentaires et ça
empilé peut nous amener à 400
TWh mais moi dans la PPE je pense que je
vais prendre 360 et j'ai une opportunité
de 40 TWh supplémentaires mais ce qui
permet comme ça de se dire on a quand
même quelques protection par rapport à
des risques qui peuvent arriver vous
savez que le pire dans le nucléaire
c'est un défaut générique
défaut générique vous mettez par terre
toutes les mêmes séries qui ont les
mêmes constructions donc ça je dire il
faut entendre les risques enfin même si
ça nous plaît pas et même si on est
beaucoup être plutôt pronucléaire le
défaut générique est un vrai risque et
donc il faut pareil l'anticiper se dire
voilà où sont mes mes zones de risque et
mes opportunités et comment je pilote ça
au mieux pour passer pour passer les
étapes sur 2035 on va rajouter donc la
con du des éoliennes marines et la
première connexion de nouveau nucléaire
arrive post 2035 donc vous ne les voyez
pas dans la programmation et nous sommes
sur un scénario de si nouveaux réacteurs
plus à
l'étude ça peut être un débat d'aller
plus loin ou pas puisque là pour le coup
le nucléaire faut quand même l'anticiper
un peu plus c'està-dire que vous pouvez
augmenter vos objectifs d'éolien sur un
pas de 2 ou 3 ans de d'éolien et de
photovoltaïque vous vous avez intérêt à
augmenter vos objectifs de nucléaire si
vous souhaitez le faire sur un pas de 15
ans donc c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
métriques euh sur la neutralité
technologique elle est parfaite dans
électricité market design elle est
parfaite dans la partie renouvelable sur
l'aviation elle est imparfaite sur la
partie renouvelable tout court mais nous
avons un acte subdélégué qui fait que
les Français
bénéficier en fait d'un système
spécifique puisque nous avons dans
l'acte subdélégué la reconnaissance que
lorsqu'on a plus de 90 % d'électricité
décarbonée du coup on compte pas de la
même manière l'hydrogène et donc on peut
faire de l'hydrogène bacarbone comme on
veut un peu près donc pour nous c'est
pas mordant pour les autres pays
européens qui ont du nucléaire il y a un
léger léger
déséquilibre comme la taxonomie est le
premier taxe qui est arrivé en ordre de
bataille AC le temps qu'on se resserre
bien les rangs de l'alliance du
nucléaire euh il est en pas complètement
parfait non plus et ce que nous comptons
faire avec l'alliance du nucléaire c'est
une plateforme on pourra vous la passer
hein évidemment pour la Commission
nucléire pour la Commission européenne
future sur voilà les positions que nous
voulons porter que nous voulons que la
Commission européenne endosse dans la
prochaine mandature avec effectivement
neutralité carbone parfaite financement
du nucléaire et pas seulement les mais
le l'ancien parce que nous encore une
fois on a la possibilité de trouver des
modes de financement tel qu'on est en
train de les trouver mais pour certains
pays c'est juste impossible enfin il va
falloir qu'ils aient une aide européenne
et eux ils comprennent pas on na pas
d'aide nous pour le renouvelable assez
peu pour le renouvelable de l'Europe on
a on n' pas d'aide pour le nucléaire
mais pour des pays de l'Est ils ont des
aides pour le renouvelable ils en nont
pas pour le nucléaire il comprennent pas
comprennent pas et on va mettre aussi
une question sur la la table qui est la
résilience de notre système et qui fait
le baselad du système parce que moi je
vais avoir un sujet un jour c'est que si
mon nucléaire je dois le baisser au
moment où les énergies renouvelables
produisent je vais moins utiliser le
nucléaire et donc mon nucléaire sera
moins compétitif alors que quand tout le
monde en aura besoin tout le monde me
dira mais qu'est-ce que tu fais faut
remonter le nucléaire donc ce petit
sujet nous voulons le mettre sur la
table en européen aussi
euh voilà réforme je vous l'ai dit
compromis européen boîte à outil oui
intégration dans la loi en tout cas de
la partie protection du consommateur ça
il y a une transcription qui est
nécessaire sur d'autres sujets c'est
plus du cadre de d'ê d'État ou de
comment on interprète les textes donc on
n pas
besoin monsieur le sénateur gu nous
sommes totalement d'accord sur le haut
niveau de sûreté et de sécurité et le
haut niveau de statut pour les salariés
puisque c'est ce qu'on fait dans le
texte alors j'entends votre point sur la
dosimétrie la dend puisqueeffectivement
ce sont sont deux équipes qui peuvent
pas se réclamer de l'équipe globale qui
bénéficie du du dispositif général donc
vous avez parfaitement
raison sur la réforme de la reine
j'accueille favorablement en tout cas
avec bienveillance le votre dans une
logique de marché avec lequel je ne suis
pas d'accord je pense que c'est une
bonne réforme 70
€ c'est pas une mauvaise réforme 70 €
est-ce que c'est assez c'est en tout cas
ce que nous disent et c'est ce travail
qu'on a fait de manière très fouillée
EDF avec des trajectoires
d'investissement qui sont je le dis
entre 20 et 25 milliards d'euros mais
pour le coup je vous laisserai
auditionner nos nos amis de DF est-ce
que je dois entendre oui ou à nouveau
puisque c'était avant la régulation donc
faut pouvoir plus vous parler j'en sais
rien peut-être dans 3 4
mois est-ce que je dois entendre qu'il
faudrait que ce soit plus haut parce que
vous voyez bien que si c'est plus haut
ça fait des tarifs plus haut pour les
Français hein un moment rien se perd
rien de se cré tout se
transforme et le fait de sortir du
marché ou d'y rester ne fait pas changer
le coût des investissements et le coût
de
production parfois même ça les augmente
le fait de sortir du marché enfin ça
c'est quid du système 110 € alors
effectivement ce que change le système
c'est que c'est un système de
prélèvement quasi fiscal qui revient
automatiquement au consommate donc il
passe pas par la case fournisseur c'est
ça sa beauté euh ce qui fait qu'on évite
effectivement d'avoir ces discussions
sur mais pourquoi euh mais comment tout
cela est reproduit et cetera sur CP1 CP2
oui ça doit revenir au consommateur il y
a un amendement qui a été déposé sur CP1
qui va pas dans ce sens-là on nous a
demandé une étude sur le sujet et une
consultation des fournisseurs
sincèrement je pense que ça doit revenir
au consommateurs c'est ce que j'entends
de la part des des
fournisseurs mais ça sera un point que
vous
examinerez sur la facture
d'électricité je je le redis alors c'est
là encore difficile de prévoir le futur
il est clair que si
EDF produit suffisamment d'électricité
pour l'ensemble du marché français ça va
être beaucoup plus facile de contenir
les prix c'est assez mathématique aussi
donc c'est le chemin que nous prenons
aujourd'hui je rappelle que si les prix
se sont envolés l'année dernière c'est
aussi parce que nous avons dû importer
l'électricité alors ce qui veut dire que
quand la France manque à l'appel ça
déséquilibre le marché européen c'est
une démonstration mais ça veut dire en
creux que si la France manque à l'appel
ça augmente les prix donc d'où
l'importance quand même que DF
fonctionne bien et produise de
l'électricité je pense que c'est un
point très important je crois que j'ai
répondu à tout le monde moi je vais être
obligé de vous quitter mais on a perdu
notre vice-président ah il arrive Daniel
est-ce qu'il tit possible de prendre ma
place si tu le veux bien puisque je vais
en conférence des présidents et je pense
que madame la ministre a environ encore
combien une dizaine de minutes donc il y
a un certain nombre de questions et je
laisse Daniel donc se prépare Daniel va
prendre la suite donc Christian Guilain
Cambier Daniel Fargeot et Henri
Cabanel ben merci Madame ou Monsieur le
Président et Madame la ministre je
voudrais quand même revenir sur une
question de méthode à propos de la loi
àire vous en avez vous en avez parlé
mais la traduction locale les consignes
des services préfectoraux également sont
un peu différents de ce que vous nous
annoncé quand vous dites que il y a pas
de de date cou près la loi à P on est
tous d'accord elle nous laisse elle
laisse aux communes jusqu'au 5 décembre
2023 pour définir les zones
d'accélération non c'est pas ce qui é
écé dans le courrier que j'ai envoyé à
l'ensemble des maires et pourtant c'est
ce que c'est pour ça que je disais il y
a un petit yatus entre ce qu'on entend
et ce qui circule sur c'est la dernière
fois que j'ai parlé au préfet sur ce
sujet ça date de la semaine dernière
dans une conférence où tous les préfets
de région on étaient représentés je vous
je vous invite à on va dire à vérifier
ou à circulariser dans ces cas-là parce
que c'est vrai que malgré les délis très
courts les territoires se saisissent du
du dossier ils sont assez volontaristes
sur ce sur ce texte il reste des
imprécision et les imprécisions
bloquantes parfois vous avez dit que les
décrets n'étaient pas là non plus
quelque chose de bloquant pour autant on
sait toujours pas ce que c'est qu'un
projet à raison impérative majeur par
exemple euh mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
la
planification sur la loi justement qui
qui qui vise à inciter les territoires
on mentionne des facilités
administratives financières et cetera or
ces incitations si on veut qu'elles soit
qu'elles soient positives euh ben elles
sont pas encore définies euh et puis par
exemple il y a des cas particuliers
comme en territoire de parc naturel
régional où il faut ajuster schémas de
déploiement et zone d'accélération et et
là aussi on n pas encore le on va dire
la conciliation entre les deux donc mes
questions elles sont relativement
relativement simple comment est-ce qu'on
arrive à tenir les délais malgré tout
avec une consultation du public dans la
réflexion des communes lorsque on n pas
des des objectifs régionalisés qui de
qui seront ensuite
donnés au territoire par les stradettes
par exemple si on prend le cas de la
région France ça veut dire que on aura
cette cet objectif qui pourrait être est
dans le Sadet qu'à partir de 2024 or on
peut pas leur demander en 2023 de faire
ce qu' n'ont pas encore ou de se
calibrer par rapport à des chiffres qui
dont ils ne disposent pas encore bref
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à motiver
les plus allant ou éventuellement ceux
qui dépasseraient le 31 décembre je dira
quelle conséquen pourrait-il pour dire
s'exposer de manière générale de façon à
être toujours les plus allents sur ce
sur ce dossier merci madame la
ministre
qui sont là que vous essz de répondre
l'ensemble
donc
Daniel bonjour madame la ministre alors
une question légère pour terminer vous
nous avez annoncé il
y exactement le leing des véhicules
électriques pour une valeur de 100 €
est-ce que vous pouvez nous communiquer
les contours de ce
dispositif oui merci président madame la
ministre deux questions d'abord une sur
l'autoconsommation avez-vous évalué les
effets de la loi
2017 sur l'aut de l'autoconsommation de
l'électricité seriez-vous favorable en
Espagne à une réduction de la TVA pour
l'installation de ces panneaux
autoconsommation de moins de 9 kg et
élargir le prix à tau zéro pour ces
investissement qui aurait un effet
positif direct sur le pouvoir d'achat
pour lequel tout votre gouvernement me
semble-t-il se bat ensuite sur l'éolien
et notamment l'éolien en mer ma région
Occitanie dans ma région Occitanie au
large de
portlanouvelle un projet pilote et on le
met d'une entreprise locale lauréate
d'un ami de l'État en 2016 est en
constru
avec quelques quand même grossse
difficulté
euh je passe sur les 27 mois d'attente
pour obtenir la notification des aides
de l'État devant la Commission
européenne vient s'ajouter à cela la
pandémie la guerre en Ukraine et bien
sûr l'inflation qui ont eu des effets
des conséquences sur l'augmentation du
coût du projet qui est passé de 212
millions d'euros à 328 millions d'euros
plus 55 % à l'instance des des mesures
d'urgence prises par votre gouver
gouvernement en juillet 2022 pour
réactualiser le prix d'achat de
l'électricité pour les autres énergies
renouvables l'éolien en mer n'a pas
bénéficié de cette mesure depuis
l'entreprise vous sollicite et ne peut
que constater un silence assourdissant
inquiétant pour le porteur de de projet
c'est rien n fait l'équilibre financier
du projet est rompu avec des
conséquences que vous pouvez imaginer
pouvez-vous remédier à cette inéquité de
traitement et revoir l'indexation du
tarif d'achat pour l'éolien en mer merci
merci Henri Philippe
Rolet merci Madame la Ministre fort
heureusement des territoires en tout cas
les acteurs des territoires n'ont pas
toujours attendu que l'État se mobilise
et j'en veux pour preuve par exemple le
territoire où je vis la Loire Atlantique
qui a vu à la fois sur la question de la
participation à la transition accueillir
le le premier parc éolien offshore en
France et et puis qui a accompagné tout
cela aussi d'une filière industrielle
vous avez occupé précédemment des
responsabilités importantes dans ce
domaine et il est évident que sur des
enjeux de cette nature il faut que les
industriels j'en veux pour preuve par
exemple général électrique qui a
implanté une usine de fabrication de
générateur anciennement Alstom et même
les Chantiers de l'Atlantique qui sont
plus connus pour construire des des
paquebau dont certains voudrait qu'il
disparaisse mais qui fonctionneront
bientôt à la voile c'est ce que nous
inventons sur nos territoires et bien
que ces industriels ont besoin de
pouvoir se projeter sur le long terme
les chtiers fabriquent des sousstations
pour les parcs éoliens qui peuvent se se
développer à l'échelle internationale et
donc Madame la Ministre quelle est la
finalement la feuille de route pour
conforter ces gros investissements qui
ont été faits sur le territoire
nous-même avons beaucoup investi par
exemple sur le Grand Port Maritime pour
qu'il soit adapté à à ces énergies
futures quelle est la feuille de route
pour que on puisse conforter le ministre
de l'Économie parlait beaucoup on parle
beaucoup de souveraineté souveraineté
alimentaire souveraineté industrielle le
ministre de l'économie en parlait hier
et il nous faut garantir à la fois la
construction de parc mais aussi la
conforte le confortement de de nos
industries pour aussi rassurer les
milliers de salariés qui aujourd'hui
travaille dans ce domaine merci merci
Philippe Vivian Artigalas merci monsieur
le Président Madame la Ministre la
planification écologique et énergétique
du gouvernement compte aussi sur une
forte mobilisation des autres acteurs
publics et privés et en premier lieu des
collectivités territoriales en effet
commune interco département et régions
portent l'essentiel de l'investissement
public et leurs besoins ont été estimés
à plus de 6,5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an d'ici 2030 dans
les seuls secteurs du bâtiment de
l'énergie et des transports malgré les
soutien ciblé de l'état de à l'action
climatique des collectivités qui sont en
hausse je le reconnais la question
question qui se pose est de savoir si
l'équation financière est tenable pour
elle au moment où c la planification
écologique et énergétique entre dans sa
phase de
territorialisation comment
l'accélération de l'action climatique
des collectivités s'intègre dans la
vision qu'a le gouvernement de
l'évolution de leurs finances à moyen
terme merci Vivian Daniel
salon merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre j'ai beaucoup de questions
mais je vais être très bref pour réponse
courte également l'hydrolien vous avez
parlé d'hydrolien tout à l'heure mais je
ne sais pas si c'était à bonciant on a 3
à 5 GW d'éolien d'hydrolien potentiel en
France une énergie prédictible et on
avance pas et on a une hydrolienne
Sabella qui est en Bretagne et qui
aujourd'hui n'a pas de tarif de rachat
qu'est-ce que l'on fait je on est
capable de faire beaucoup de choses en
France mais sur l'hydrolien ça a l'air
de d'être difficile autre chose plus un
peu en forme de c'est pas une boutade
mais quand démarrera le Pr de
Flamanville et à quel prix sera le mgaw
pour une tête de série qui n'a pas de
série même chose dans le même ordre
d'idée vous avez dit 15 15 à 20
% du budget de DF pour le nouveau
nucléaire c'est 15 à 20
% sans dérapage c'est bien ça je je
suppose parce que vous savez qu'on a
souvent des mauvaises surprises avec le
nucléaire quand
quant quant aux énergies
renouvelables la CRE nous indique 13,7
milliards d'euros de recett 2023 vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure est-ce que
vous confirmez bien ce chiffre et puis
effectivement on a une là une industrie
mature et qui fonctionne sans
combustible donc voilà on voit
aujourd'hui tout l'intérêt du
renouvelable et je m'arrêterai là merci
merci Daniel
Bernardi merci monsieur le Président
rapidement deux questions madame la
ministre après avoir été annoncé puis
voté la relance du nucléaire est
désormais acté en témoigne ce projet de
loi de finance pour 2024 qui augmente de
plus d' 1,5 milliards d'euros le budget
dédié au nucléaire cela représente un
budget en hausse de 10 % néanmoins
comment se concrétisera cette
augmentation budgétaire dans quelle
mesure sera-t-elle dédiée au financement
des SMR ma deuxième question porte sur
la sobriété énergétique madame la
ministre il y a un mois lors d'un
colloque vous avez souligné la nécessité
de faire de la sobriété une habitude si
nos concitoyens semblent être con cerné
par le sujet comme on témoigne des
données relevées l'hiver dernier les
entreprises ont également une
responsabilité en la matière s'agissant
de l'encadrement de l'éclairage des
bureaux et des vitrines que compte faire
le gouvernement pour inciter davantage à
la sobriété
énergétique merci beaucoup Bernard je
m'associerai à la question de Daniel sur
l'hydrolienne vous le savez parce qu'il
y en a une aussi dans le département
desbuches qui n'a pas de tarif de rachat
et c'est une commodité d'ACL qui s'est
substitué à l'absence de arrive d'
rachat alors que c'est une fabrication
100 % française madame la
ministre alors
euh sur la question de du calendrier de
planification énergétique je rappelle
qu'il a été défini par les députés les
sénateurs c'est pas le gouvernement qui
l'a défini je je le précise parce que
c'est toujours important de se rappeler
comment la loi est faite et que moi
j'avais attiré l'attention sur le fait
que c'était rapide et qu'on m'avait dit
vous manquez d'ambition je permet de le
de le signaler néanmoins comme nous
sommes des gens pragmatiques j'ai
effectivement et donc vous pouvez le
rapporter à vos aux élus locaux avec
lesquels vous êtes en contact et je peux
vous transmettre le courrier qui va avec
rappelez à l'ensemble des maires et des
présidents d'intercommunalité que la
date que l'on on leur demandait de
remonter une leur planification les
zones d'accélération était fixé au 31
décembre de cette année le 5 décembre
c'est je crois la la mise en œuvre
automatique de la loi 31 décembre de
cette année que néanmoins c'était pas
une date coup prês et leur donner en
fait toute la boîte à outil référents
préfectoral qui ont été donc tous nommés
portail cartographique qui est d qui est
en ligne depuis le mois de juin qui va
faire une montée de version enfin qui
fait des montées de version régulières
euh portail d'entraide dis enfin genre
quelqu'un aurait-il un exemple de
délibération que je puisse recopier
enfin voilà on met des documents comme
ça qui permettent de faire gagner du
temps aux élus euh et de faire des
questions-réponses et euh les fiches
Adem qui permettent aussi d'avoir en
quatre pages et vraiment je vous invite
à les regarder parce que c'est très bien
fait euh tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
euh l'éolien terrestres le
photovoltaïque sur toiture le
photovoltaïque au sol euh enfin voilà de
façon à faire gagner la gé l'hydro la
géothermie et cetera avoir les notions
de coût de durée de projet de problèmes
plus ou moins euh de dans la conduite
des projets euh de façon à aider les les
élus qui sont quand même pas tous
spécialistes du géit thmique à se
se prendre leur décisions donc ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point c'est
que j'annoncerai au au au au salon des
ma aussi des des outils complémentaires
pour permettre de faciliter les choses
et qu'en fait on va gérer autant que
possible les collectivités locales qui
prennent de l'avance pour leur permettre
de continuer et celles qui ont besoin
d'un peu plus d'accompagnement et
sincèrement les situations sont très
différenciées sur le territoire et c'est
normal pour leur permettre de respirer
un petit peu pas de zone d'accélération
c'est la loi antérieure qui s'applique
donc il y a pas d'effet cliquer
simplement c'est la loi antérieure
s'agissant des stradet on a fait un
exercice je fais le tour de toutes les
régions les Haut- de- France ont eu
cette conversation avec mes équipes qui
est en gros vous donner l'idée je
préfère qu'on fasse en parallèle une
discussion un peu en chambre et pas
parfaite avec chacune des des régions et
leurs objectif seradet à revoir en plus
chacun n'a pas le même rythme de
révision de ces seradettes en parallèle
de la loi énergie climat enfin la loi de
production énergétique de façon à ce que
en gros on puisse se dire bah quand je
fais l'addition de ce que vous pourriez
réhausser en chambre dans vos stradet ça
ne colle pas avec ma loi nationale et
donc de mettre en évidence les impasses
et donc on a fait cet exercice
c'està-dire on a pris les objectifs
d'estradet à
2030 la réalisation ses objectifs à
2023 et un calcul un peu théorique avec
trois méthodes
différentes sur contenu de ce que nous
nous réhaussons dans la vision nationale
qu'est-ce que ça donnerait pour les
sradettes de chacune des régions alors
ça veut vous faire sourire parce qu'en
gros la région des haut-fan a fait
quasiment 200 % de son objectif en
néoléen voz je voilà puis il y a
d'autres régions qui sont pas tout à
fait fait ça euh donc ça donne un peu
des des billes et en fait l'idée c'est
de regarder par rapport à ce qu'on sait
du potentiel de la dynamique observée
dans la région de ce que dit stradet qui
est un acte politique sur les choix
sous-jacents de mix énergétique bon sous
réserve que les régions n'ont pas changé
de patron
euh ce que ça projette pour 2030 et
ensuite on en discute avec de manière
informelle encore une fois avec bah
écoutez nous on pense que là vous en
mettez trop sur leséolien je sais pas
quoi sur le photovoltaïque et pas assez
sur autre chose de façon à avoir quelque
chose qui est un peu théorique et qui
vous donne à vous une vision qui est pas
très on est grossièrement raison
collectivement et ensuite tout ça
imprimera dans le détail donc vous avez
raison on est en train de paralléliser
des choses qui devraent être
séquentielles si on était séquentiel on
y serait jusqu'en 2026 si on parallélise
Chac chacun peut continuer à agir en
ayant grosso modo l'image nationale ce
que ça veut dire de son image régionale
et peut discuter en disant cette image
régionale ne correspond pas à ce que je
pressends de la réalité et on fait ça
région par
région sur le leasing à 100 € l'idée
c'est de le lancer donc avant la fin de
l'automne ce qui est le 21 décembre
comme vous le savez
tous c'est une c'est un dispositif qui
permet d'avoir effectivement à 100 € par
mois l'accès à un véhicule électrique en
fait l'assurance n'est pas comprise sauf
l'assurance décès l'assurance invalidité
l'assurance perte d'emploi euh et vous
avez des véhiculle dont le tarif est
inférieur à 100 € par mois des tarifs
dont le véhicule est supérieur à 100 €
par mois parce que c'est lié aussi aux
caractéristiques de ces véhicules
néanmoins ça permet d'avoir cette offre
sur aujourd'hui
euh du côté de 20000 véhicules
électrique pour l'année
2024 en fonction aussi des véhicules qui
sont produits en Europe en France en
petite cylindrée vous savez qu'il y a un
certain nombre de véhicules soit qui
vont être en fin de production c'est
vrai pour la Twingo et la Zoé soit
qu'ils vont démarrer leur production je
pense notamment à la C3 par exemple donc
et ce dispositif a vocation à monter en
puissance ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est
que on va probablement tester l'intérêt
des Français parce que quand on regarde
le bonus écologique le bonus écologique
c'est très peu de véhicules c'est
quelques c'est 20000 30000 véhicules
30000 véhicules pour
euh les revenus de référence de 1 à 3 ou
quatre jeux pas dire de bêtises mais
c'est dans ces uxl donc c'est congruent
mais peut-être c'est un dispositif qui
va beaucoup plus intéresser les gens ou
peut-être pas parce qu'on sait que dans
les
habitudes de consommation des Français
certains sont attéchés à être
propriétaire de leur véhicule et n' pas
juste le louer donc c'est ça que nous
devons que nous devons préciser et on va
avancer comme comme cela et ça sera
accompagné aussi d'une révision des
barêes bonus écologique prime à la
conversion encore une fois moi mon
objectif c'est de ramener au plus près
véhicules thermiques véhicules
écologiques sur des petites cylindrées
de façon à avoir des vraies solutions
pour les gens vraies solutions pour les
gens et puis à côté on déploie et on
continue à déployer des bandes de
recharge et on a augmenté aussi le
crédit d'impôt sur les bandes de
recharge le droit à la prise et sur et
on finance avec les C2E l'installation
dans les copropriétés donc on peut
déployer sur
l'autoconsommation préat
Z0
alors moi je vais lancer une mission sur
l'autauonsommation pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord l'observation à
l'international montre que
l'autoconsommation s'est développée à
toute vitesse et là n nous nous
observons une accélération absolument
massive de l'autoconsommation premier
point 2ème point on a le sentiment que
le collectif est peut-être plus
intéressant que l'individuel troisème
point il y a pas de PV thermique en
France or ça paraît bizarre parce que le
PV thermique le photovoltaïque thermique
ça devrait être une solution au moins
dans le sud de la France qui répond
assez bien un certain nombre d'usages or
des gens qui veulent développer du PV
thermique ne trouvent pas les filières
ne trouvent pas les les panneaux et
cetera donc il y a vraiment des trous
dans la raquette sur ce sujet-là 4e
sujet c'est la contribution au réseau
euh pour ceux qui en fait ce
développement là peut amener
à réincter quand même avoir donc des
infrastructures qui sont installées sans
payer le coût du réseau et donc à un
moment ça veut dire qu'il y a une forme
de péréquation qu'il faut regarder enfin
dernier élément mais c'est comme dans
toute la le travail que nous devons
faire c'est la question de
euh l'ajustement offre demande de
production dans la journée et dans
l'année où il faut qu'on regarde les
implications que ça peut avoir sur ce
qui garantit la le reste de la sécurité
de notre approvisionnement et s'agissant
de la France et beaucoup le nucléaire
puisque on a vocation à
sortir du du du gaz qui qui est l'autre
élément de de pilotage de notre réseau
sur lesoliers en mer l'objectif alors le
dossier on l'a bien dans le viseur on
partage votre niveau de préoccupation et
euh mes équipes sont je peux pas en dire
plus à ce stade mais
je et j'ai bien entendu également ce
pointlà sur la filière industrielle
offshore c'est formidable ce qui est
fait par la filière industrielle je
pense notamment au sousstation et on est
exportateur ce qui est incroyable parce
que on a connecté aujourd'hui deux parcs
donc on est plutôt pas les plus en
avance en Europe il y a un sujet de
carnet de commande vous avez un trou
d'air sur les carnets de commande dans
les 2 ans qui viennent et et derrière
vous allez avoir une remontée très
pentue vous avez également des acteurs
internationaux qui s'intéressent à ce
marché et qui pourrait nous refaire une
photovoltaïque ce dont on n pas envie la
on a alerté la Commission européenne qui
a lancé un grand plan sur le sur
l'éolien je sais pas si ça va assez loin
pour être honnête il faut vraiment qu'on
regarde dans le détail mais
effectivement l'enjeu c'est de donner le
plus de visibilité possible sur ces
acteurs et de faire en sorte a qu'on
soit très attentif nous on le fait au
travers d'un Pact éolien et d'un pacte
solaire à ce qu'il est de l'achat en
France et en Europe privilégié sur
d'autres solutions et c'est un enjeu de
souveraineté vous disiez monsieur le
sénateur salmont ce qui est formidable
avec les EnR c'est que c'est compétitif
j'adhère ce qui est formidable c'est que
ça nécessa pas nécessite pas de
carburant j'adère enfin de oui carburant
j'adhère en revanche nous sommes
dépendants sur les composants et ça ça
reste un sujet qui est majeur et sur
lequel il faut qu'on qu'on agisse euh
sur madame la sénatrice
Artigalas alors la question de comment
les collectivités locales financent leur
propre transition énergétique c'est un
des sujets effectivement qui a vocation
à être traité dans les COP régionales
par une vision partagée sur les projets
et les modalités de financement on fait
quand même à Paris c'est qu'une partie
des investissements des collectivités
locales vont être comment dire réorienté
vers la transition écologique
énergétique et et et que tout le monde y
est prêt et qu'en fait c'est pas
forcément que de l'additionnel mais ça
peut être aussi de la transformation
c'estàd il y a des projets qui ont moins
d'intérêt dans cette nouvelle vision et
auxquel on renoncera probablement et des
projets qui ont plus d'intérêt auxquels
on ira 2uxième chose certains projets
ont un vrai intérêt sur la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments dont on a
l'usage et qui sont euh dépassoir
thermique vous gagnez sur la facture
c'est pour ça qu'on a lancé et que vous
avez voté le tiersfinancement et c'est
pour ça qu'on doit continuer à
développer des systèmes qui permettent
en fait de valoriser les économies et de
faire du coup les investissements en
amont et ensuite vous vous vous avez
[Musique]
un ça ne facilite pas la
vie éta sur les économies d'énergie en
fait et là du coup on dépasse et le
reste à charge augmente ça qu'on fa plus
de sobriété je vous jure que la sobriété
je vous donne un chiffre 6 % des
bâtiments en France ont une gestion
technique des bâtiments 6 % ça nous
laisse 94 % de
d'amélioration et une gestion technique
des bâtiments c'est - 15 % de
consommation d'énergie en moyenne enfin
ça ouvre quand même des perspectives
ouais mais pas de même niveau pas aussi
structurant et un peu moins
impactant sur sur les hydr
je hydrolienne marine nous avons un
projet qui a un tarif de rachat qui est
flowat nous en regardons un deuxième sur
les hydroliennes ça c'est dans les
vouges donc c'est pas tout à fait
marin je et ça fonctionne je vous le
redis et c'est ça ça me semble pas aussi
enfin en tout cas il y a on a
effectivement pas de pas de dossier en
la matière faire simple sur flamandville
3 la date c'est
2024 sur le coup c'est illustré je crois
très clairement dans la le papier de la
creux donc c'est un réhaussement de
l'ordre de 3 € du coup du
mgaw
nucléaire sur les recettes des énergies
renouvelables vous mentionnez 13
milliards d'euros et vous savez que vous
avez le bon chiffre merci beaucoup je
crois que j'ai ah non lessmr monsieur le
sénateur Bui euh c'est ce qui est
financé
effectivement dans le budget c'est
notamment le réhaussement de 200
millions d'euros qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière ça il y a la poursuite du
projet Jul rovitz qui est absolument
indispensable aussi pour le nouveau
nucléaire mais également pour la
recherche en santé c'est le financement
des recrutements du CEA 126 ETP et euh
c'est le financement de nouvelle
infrastructure de recherche pour
anticiper les besoins expérimentaux des
technologies portées par des start-ups
l'ureéat de l'appel à projet réacteur
nucléaire innovant vous savez qu'il y a
une enveloppe dans France 2030 pour ces
réacteurs innovants on a déjà de lauréa
il y a 15 projets qui sont aujourd'hui
dans le pack ça veut pas dire qu'ils
vont tous transformer ça veut dire
qu'ils sont tous regardés et ils font
l'objet de d'urau pour voir si quel est
leur niveau de sérieux et de capacité
d'aboutissement donc oui on est en train
alors les deux que j'ai Mo donc nuard
des subventionné ça c'est le projet EDF
qui est un peu plus mature mais qui
n'est pas uneveau une innovation
technologique transformante il y a deux
projets nucléo et Nara qui sont soutenus
mais qui sont un peu moins mat
et qui sont des technologies
transformantes notamment sur la la
réutilisation du combustible ça ça
devrait faire plaisir à monsieur le
sénateur Salmon et il y en a 15 qui sont
avec des technologies différentes et
qu'on est en train de regarder pour leur
mérite propre l'idée étant effectivement
d'avoir un portefeuille de projets les
plus innovants pour pouvoir continuer à
alimenter notre connaissance tous
n'iront pas au bout mais tous
apporteront un meilleur niveau de jeu à
la filière nucléaire française sur la so
énergétique je le redis c'est vraiment
un levier c'est le moins cher c'est
celui qui a le retour sur investissement
le plus rapide et vous avez énormément
de bénéfices derrière encore faut-il les
mettre en évidence et et sortir
effectivement juste de la baisse de CO2
mais c'est une amélioration de la
qualité de l'air c'est l'amélioration
des régimes alimentaires moins de
maladiie chronique c'est l'amélioration
enfin c'est l'amélioration du du confort
de vie c'est plus de biodiversité très
rapidement la pollution lumineuse c'est
en quelques mois que vous voyez la
transformation vous c'est vraiment des
bénéfices locaux pour les gens et c'est
ça qu'il faut mettre en avant alors une
fois qu'on a dit ça vous avez raison les
entreprises ont une responsabilité c'est
pour ça que moi j'en ai fait un des
acteurs forts toutes les entreprises du
CAC40 ont un plan on a demandé à toutes
les entreprises du SBF 120 d'avoir un
plan d'abord parce que ça fait de la
masse tout simplement ensuite parce que
ça fait l'exemplarité vis-à-vis de leurs
salariés et sur l'éclairage j'ai pris
avec Sarah la
agit avec sa casquette biodiversité moi
j'agis avec ma casquette économie
d'énergie euh donc je suis en train de
concerter sur des arrêtés qui vont dire
pas d'éclairage des bureaux et de
l'intérieur des vitrines 1 heure enfin 1
heure après le départ des salariés et 1
heure avant la reprise du travail et par
ailleurs des amendes administrative
parce que c'est plus facile que de
passer par le juge et les mairres qui
veulent faire la police pourront la
faire facilement ils seront pas voilà et
c'est très simple et tout le monde
comprend c'est comme le PV parce que
vous êtes
malgaré merci beaucoup merci Madame
ministre de d'avoir consacré 2 heures à
notre commission merci aux commissaires
qui sont restés jusqu'à la fin et puis
je pense que on va vous dire à très
bientôt contenu des sujets importants
qu'on a évoqué un peu tout à l'heure
mais qui sont en train de se précipiter
devant nous merci bonne soirée merci
expation
słamo